all righty citizens of the reject Nation
you know what time it is
let us know that we are live
it is I and we're here to talk about our
favorite YouTubers today so we're
excited just as much to hear your
feedback because you know I mean I gotta
imagine we all have a slightly different
taste even though we converge over
movies there will be some wild cards
here hey what's yes yes Ryan George
already he's in the thumbnail you know
what it's about NASCAR is that is there
a NASCAR YouTube channel do they have
their own web content I'm gonna blow the
chat up really quick so if the window
gets messed up I apologize you know how
we do always figuring it out in the
moment uh how's it going Audrey Saint
Seer Marvel Thunder Zay Chase Elliott
Wednesday happy birthday yesterday I
don't know which Friday the 13th
Wednesday Adams was born on but uh it
was one of them and uh hey I hope your
day was happy as well there's a cat
walking around on the floor by my
computer it's cool though
uh just stay Ragu what's up dude Nate
linner a wandie big dude Wilson p a lot
of good rhyming names in the chat today
appreciate y'all red hot comic book
movie news that's right jtvo you you
guys are good at reading the thumbnail
so uh you probably know a few of the
people we're gonna talk about today
hello Juan uh uh Julian Mendez hello uh
DBZ Arts do people call you dbzarts is
that a problem that you face frequently
what's going on Edgar Martinez we're
about to talk about our favorite not
only our favorites but the best
YouTubers objectively objectively so if
yours don't make the list then you
should stop following them and uh
they're no good and you heard it here
and you can let them know that we said
that we encourage beef it's good for
engagement on the Chanel joining me as
always is is the founder of the feast
the creator of uh this operation Greg
Alba
how how do you introduce the host host
when you're the co-host
joining me is my host today and every
day most of the time crack Albert Mr
Angry Joe hey I've seen some Angry Joe
for sure hey Brandon's in the chat
Brandon Melgar no way dude hi everybody
shirts for you Brandon they're they're
your Christmas your birthday presents
get your ass over here Brandon a3c films
from Tavares yes love 3C films I'm
jealous of him because he's good at
horror stuff all righty John thank you
for holding it down any old time to do
social media posts since we are when I'm
like on the camera
yeah that's good
um so so how's it going John it's so
good I'm excited to share some love
today alrighty
um look hey so there's a couple of
things
that I wanted to mention first off first
talk is gonna be some hot takes oh no
we're also going to talk about who sucks
today it's all Geeks and Gamers
yeah yeah yeah Andrew Tate I love it I
got I got a bunch of them I love this
YouTube no um so with the I was this
thumbnail sometimes these thumbnails are
always like the most daunting things to
me sure and with this one in particular
there was something I was back and forth
on I was telling John we were trying to
compose it one is I was like all right I
don't want to put anyone on here who I
talk with like who's just a real friend
I talk with regularly because we've made
so many call colleagues over the years
here that I'm like all right so heavy
spoilers isn't going on this thumbnail
the original thumbnail was just heavy
spoilers and Cosmic wonder and neither
of us because if I put just one of them
then the other one's gonna be like goose
who looks more like I don't wanna deal
with that yeah and the other one was
like all right and I also know so many
reactors so many reaction channels stuff
like I have to put one on here then I
don't want them to be like what was an
eye on there so did you that that's why
I like people like get shabby aren't on
there right and um the and then the
other part of it that I was like here's
where I was really back and forth on and
I'm going to be really honest about this
as a dude was I was like there is no
women on this thumbnail oh and I was
like all right I could play the politics
here and just put a woman on here sure
why not just because but I was very I
was honest with myself and I was like
okay like I have I gotten to know many
like women uh like through this space
you know people like Perry nemeroff who
I knew before I got to know her before I
realized she was doing anything YouTube
related or
um you know like Sally lamonico uh
Lauren Francesca when he detects back
God damn it or Laura Francesca uh Roxy
stryer is a great a great personality on
YouTube the terror Erickson there's so
many people I know and it's like in
terms of like channels that I've watched
quite a bit of it's like Natalie gold
and Mary Cherry indeed she's always
watching like other reactors as well but
I realize and I could use suggestions
from you guys that I don't watch and I
think it might be the same for you is I
don't really watch enough of like female
shooting content yeah female driven
YouTubers I I don't other than like some
of the reactors I listed off or some of
the people who I've I've known but again
that's why I was saying like the
category for how I was putting this
thumbnail together uh and I do like I
don't know enough female you I don't
watch enough female YouTubers regularly
like people at home just fans of Hawaii
who I just don't know you know I don't
know this person but you know shouts out
to pay or wait I like her reviews a lot
I like her discussions of movies and
stuff like that and pay weight if you
haven't seen her Channel go check her
out and uh it's funny I find I find
myself watching more female content
creators in different spaces like if I'm
trying to learn about psychology or
something like that but yeah I would
like to find more like female
entertainment based YouTubers as well I
watch a lot of Psych to go sure but I
don't see a face there so I like the
what's her name doctor is her name is
Tracy marks I think yeah she's got a
good Channel I like her her explorations
of different uh you know just like
psychology topics but I've seen psycho
what is it psychology to go psych to go
psych to go yeah I've seen some of their
videos yeah and uh and you know there
yeah it's like there will be channels
like I love wisecrack and they have like
an occasional they have um blanking on
her name now but they have a female host
but not like the Lion's Share of the
time so it doesn't like fully count I
guess yeah like I've seen
um uh yeah girlfriend reviews I've
listened to a good amount of girlfriend
reviews
uh and like Natalie go ahead yes
I'm talking specifically why they were
on the thumbnail yeah yeah because yeah
I could have easily just slapped a girl
in there I'm like no I want to be honest
with myself here and I want and I was
like also I was thinking about it and
like most of the people who I watch
regularly have come to me via
recommendations sure I don't like
actively search yeah and like okay is
this like an algorithm thing that about
my demographic or is it just a I could
put more of an effort in to find more
people later so it's a little bit
recommend your algorithm yeah exactly
recommend more internet Monash I don't
know who that is
is going to keep a side tab off screen
oh let's see I watched a lot of Natalie
gold oh actually uh I thought it was
easily I thought it was an h s in there
for Ashley burden or is there no s there
she's got great reactions too oh and she
can't stand Natalie gold she's the [ __ ]
and she's awesome oh dude love to
Natalie gold don't don't don't be trash
talking Natalie gold I mean shouts out
to the homegirl uh Mama's geeky you know
Mama's geek Big Love For Mama so yes
yeah
all right all right let's get to it
absolutely let's get to it I appreciate
it so Atlanta Parker I don't know who
that is I'm gonna write that down
holding hard on thank you thank you
Landa Parker I haven't seen Star Wars
girl now no no no but who do you guys
watch regularly let's let's hear it guys
who do you guys watch regularly
Star Wars as girl I don't know who that
is
and holding heart in I'm writing them
down I'll land a Parker I want to get
more acquainted because I've been
wanting to check out more like expanding
my palette here so thank you guys for
being here please leave a like and uh
let's get this show on the road here so
John who would you let's just kick it
off let's not [ __ ] around who'd you
say your favorite YouTube channel is of
2022. of 2022
I almost feel like we're gonna come out
with the same answer because there's
there's one show I listened to above all
others both for just the joy like
there's certain shows where you know
you're always listening to what's
current but you can go back and you can
listen to some obscure episode just
because you you like the personality and
uh I think it would be Mr Sunday Mr
Sunday movie I think Mr Sunday is the
one I go to the most and I have just the
most like ah like I wish I could kick it
with these guys like like Double Toasted
is my all-timer because like they were
spill.com in high school like I I
remember getting they were like the
first channel I ever started following
and then tracked through their evolution
and have never fallen off of so I guess
for All Times Sake I would say that but
like for who like really kind of jetted
to the front of my consumption for 2022
I think it would definitely have to be
Mr Sunday
that's funny because I'm thinking about
my the channels that I would often
fluctuate between who is my favorite was
Mr Sunday movies and Double Toasted and
I'm realizing you introduced me to both
of them what yeah I didn't know of them
until you introduced me to them a long
time ago that's crazy and like I know
I've introduced Sunday really yeah I
didn't watch Mr Sunday movie and then
and then I I felt I I can get I can
become a bit obsessive so yeah if I fall
down a wormhole where I'm just like now
I'm only listening to like this person
and going years back so yeah totally
there was there's so many uh so yeah I
I've like I I constantly consume them or
they're they're easily I I would Edge
out to uh weekly it was funny because
out of everyone only on a thumbnail that
I'm like I legit know is is Corey but I
didn't really get to know him until like
a few months ago yeah and um so now we
we do talk talk but
um yeah so I don't think he'd be
watching this live stream anyway but
yeah but not sometimes it's either like
it's that kind of it's like when you ask
me where my favorite movie is Terminator
2 or Matrix sometimes I switch right now
in this moment in time for being honest
with myself it's like I'm pretty
addicted to like Mr Sunday movie because
I think what both of those channels
provide me with is the the feeling that
sometimes people have said here because
I was kind of honest about this on
Twitter is before doing YouTube we
weren't really
I I personally didn't watch YouTube
before we did YouTube like I was just
looking for a way to to like is there a
way to like do movie reviews and get
paid for it because that's what I really
just wanted to do was just review movies
and get paid for it and because I just
wanted to quit my job and so I didn't
even know that you could like make a
good living off of you I didn't know any
of that so I didn't watch any YouTubers
so it's through the Journey of doing
YouTube where I started finding uh more
people and so sometimes we would get
comments of you know people being like
Oh you guys are good Escape is um yeah
you know you guys make me feel really
happy help me out with my depressions
and [ __ ] like that that sometimes people
say to us that I have a hard time uh
buying into or subscribing to like
accepting that and and I didn't quite
really generate those feelings until
those channels when I was like oh this
is what that feeling is like this is
like yeah hanging out with a buddy and
just yeah like listening to it's like
joining in a chat about a movie you
wanted to talk about yeah yeah yeah
where I'm like I didn't I did not know
that feeling until them yeah basically
you know because I was like I watched
like a lot of Jeremy Johns I still do
you know and we've we've met him a few
times and uh he's an insanely nice guy
in person and it was really funny very
eccentric personality yeah yeah you
think he's got a lot of energy in his
videos he's an Accenture guy and and uh
he's he's about as like he's more he's
even I think he's even bigger in person
than he is in on his videos oh sure and
I'm talking about Cosmos or something
like that yeah yeah he's the kind of guy
who you could like just shoot the [ __ ]
with about a bunch of random stuff yeah
it's a fantastic guy to talk to you
um but it was when I was like oh I'm
really binging a lot of Double Toasted
in Mr Sunday movies and I and I'm like
I'm wishing I was there in the room with
them I'm wishing I was hanging out with
them banter I'm having a I'm having a
little bit of difficult time right now
and I'm listening to them and I'm
feeling good now so yeah they're they're
easily my my favorites I I would I would
say so yeah we got a couple of super
chats I want to make sure we I got like
a few hours of editing to do today so
I'm gonna try to keep this this live
stream a tad bit on track but you got
I'm also as I'm talking I'm also reading
the chat that is on screen yeah
um please leave a like if you are here
even if you're gonna be here for like a
minute please leave a like leave a like
and also if you're also here what I
wanted to mention too what let me just
pull it up on the actual chat can we
yeah I'm just making sure that uh that
I'm making sure that the chat goes all
the way back to the first one I wanted
to mention that
um this is this is important I'm going
to do a little short about it tomorrow
that for the 300 people that are here
John and I are not going to be covering
the last of us together
so here's what we're going to be doing
because I've played the games uh both
times two times each I love them and I
wanted to experience it as a gamer fan
and especially with the commentary in
perspective so I'm covering it with
Andrew Gordon who I've obsessively
talked about the game with John is going
to be covering it with Tara Erickson
because she was the only other person I
could find
it's familiar Sterling who also has not
played the game as I was like it would
be fun to get two different kinds of
reactions here because I was like all
right if I'm in the same video John I'd
definitely be like
really mincing my commentary and if
you're saying a lot of stuff or don't be
like oh okay I guess something's coming
why is Greg reacting to that I don't
understand
why so it was like it would be cool to
have two different kinds of reactions on
this channel so there's going to be sep
they're gonna be separated and John's
gonna be doing them where it's like the
person who hasn't played the game people
haven't played the game and then the
people who have played the game but I'm
excited for it I'm the most anticipated
show of the year and it's January yeah
isn't that nice January is shape it up
to be a thick month with Megan and now
the last of us like
um so we got Mr domest thank you for the
super chat buddy
um best YouTubers of 2022 easy answer
real rejects I don't think so but
appreciate it yeah I think that's very
very kind to you it's very sweet of you
thank you for saying that 2021 was the
peak all that Spider-Man no way home
coverage
um yeah Chris stuckman I think is
another fantastic movie reviewer there's
a lot of people that it's a funny thing
is I've got to know a lot of people you
know I know John Camp it could be of a
controversial subject but I love
watching him oh he's so fun to watch
he's so fun I want to I want to be there
in person when campia is losing his [ __ ]
yes like what is it gonna take for me to
to get in front of you in here how can I
prove that to be the cause of it I gotta
provoke him in some way to just let out
all his rad yeah that's the thing I'm
really holding on you gotta do something
like willfully stupid or something like
that yes yeah Mr domez thank you for the
Super Chat funny little gal reacts I'm
gonna write that down I don't know who
that is this is good load us up load us
up and then in 20 the 2023 retrospective
will be only women on the thumbnail
might as well yeah it is and then
recommend your favorite child YouTubers
because that won't get difficult
let's go back let's catch him elon's
musk I like that one smell that oh I
don't know what any oh I know coffee
Zilla coffee Zilla is a wonderful sure
yeah
um I don't know these other ones it
links are the Super Chat top five
channels of 2022 number one is Kane
pixels what is Kane pixels number two
it's Kane hotters John quickly theorized
for 10 seconds what each one of these
channels is all right uh Kane pixels is
a retelling in of the Cain and Abel
story but an 8-bit animation Voice verse
is about boys who are perverts yes
definitely uh maxor is a guy named Max
who lives at the Luxor in Vegas and he
just Vlogs his life Wendy goon is about
witchcraft yes definitely absolutely you
got a wide variety there
you really love interests
yes now I'm gonna I'm gonna screenshot
this check them out all out you know we
got Ryan George on the thumb and I want
to make sure we shot everyone on this
thumbnail yes
um because I know what happens on the
playbacks people are like when do they
talk about this guy uh Ryan George uh is
to me a massive inspiration for the
possibilities on YouTube what he managed
to there's a I haven't talked to this
person in ages but a person I brought on
before Casey Spivey
um I was trying to call her name I was
like it's not Kevin's face
he's surviving uh she she uh she used to
work at Screen Rant she said Ryan George
mentored her and and that he's uh a
really incredible helpful guy and seeing
what he did with pitch meetings and how
influential that's become and how I've
heard other people talk about in a lot
of ways he did not not just as I know
some people screen junkies too uh not
the slight screen junk he's been in a
lot of ways I feel like what pitch
what's in it the void that cinema sins
and honest trailers
um for a lot of people still fills and
at one point completely filled I really
feel like pitch meeting has really
filled that right now where now I'll
watch it and even from my end I will
find myself thinking at times this is
when Ryan George is going to say super
easy barely inconvenience this is what
he's going to point out sometimes I see
things in that lens where like the I
remember the Russo Brothers uh them
talking about uh when writing crafting
civil uh no Winter Soldier they we spoke
about how they wanted to make an honest
trailers proof and I really do feel like
with pitch meetings you make a pitch
proof you're going to want to make a
pitch meeting proof now yeah and on top
of that
how he managed to then grow his own
channel like be a lot of people try to
like uh Branch out and do their own
thing or do something separate and how
Ryan George managed to create his own
channel that is now massive in every
video he does does extremely well and
it's not Pitch meeting it's it's an it's
a great transition if you love pitch
meeting and then you want these other
stuff because it's still in the same
style but it's not the same Concepts and
I think that's really really impressive
and inspiring to see someone be able to
because I always talk about if you want
to like start doing other things you
gotta transition into it instead of like
major swings and to me he he did a
masterful transition you know to be able
to keep pitch meeting going and to be
able to do his own content as well yeah
like oh my goodness I I wish I had and
and two I mean I could see how you know
continually doing the same show might
get tedious but at the same time I feel
like there's just a
I hesitate to say anything is like the
perfect take because as we've seen like
you know things have you know their Peak
life span and then they you know persist
and and they maintain but like yeah it's
like you said that that void that cinema
sins and honest trailers used to fill
solely I could see Pitch meeting kind of
filling forever because there's
something so good-natured about what he
does like even though he's pointing and
not just to suggest that like honest
trailers at least is not good-natured
but there's something especially kind of
fun about the way he's poking at these
movies and pointing out the holes and so
you know some movies lend themselves
better than others but I feel like yeah
making yourself pitch proof is kind of a
funny thing that a lot of filmmakers
probably are kind of doing right now and
I appreciate that he's not at least in
doing his thing it's never
mean
or or you know like really a dismissive
of whatever's at hand and I think that's
a nice thing uh let's see here ooga
booga I don't know who that is
um oh double toaster does have the best
bad movie reviews oh I would love I love
stuff like that you know who I oh I
really do like
um
he's so cynical and I think sometimes we
put out people who are like they're too
cynical for me that sometimes they'll
shout people out yeah and
um uh YMS yeah yeah as you said cynical
I was like it must be he I think he is I
think he's hysterical like I'm never
upset at what he I think that's the
thing is as much as people often credit
us we're trying to be more optimistic in
our takes as often as we can
um I love some of these like very
cynical like takes that people have that
I don't like wrathful [ __ ] I don't like
where you're like how can I get mad at
the woke mob or something or were people
like obviously like what little thing
could I nitpick here oh I'm gonna make a
whole video about that and capitalize
off rage like that is not the thing I
I'm a fan of but if you're doing like a
full video like it's Lion King review or
the countless reviews he's done uh you
know I think he's so I think he's a
really funny guy yeah I do too he's got
the right pitch for his Sinister me
where I know half the time I'm probably
not going to share the opinion and I'll
probably be like I wouldn't go that hard
on whoever it is but there's something
that's a hard kind of humor for me to
really click on and I really click on
YMS videos and I think of I think it's
he's usually not talking to you as if
you also think it's stupid it just
sounds like he's sharing you know his
dismay with whatever he's taking in if
it happens to be a negative review
whereas there are people like like I've
never really gotten into Doug Walker's
stuff like uh Angry is he Angry Video
Game Nerd
um like Doug Walker is a guy who's like
always talks to me like I think whatever
he thinks is stupid also is stupid and
and oftentimes I don't and so like
that's the keys like with YMS I'm like
yeah we don't have to agree and it
doesn't seem like you even care if I do
agree you're talking about nostalgic
Nostalgia Critic yeah sorry not angry
video game or a Nostalgia Critic yeah
it's like I've always found that barrier
of like I can tell that you think I also
think this is stupid and I might not
yeah and that's that's the barrier that
YMS doesn't present me with and uh and
yeah I could listen to him trash movies
all day or love movies like it's always
a very rewarding thing when Adam's
actually like I kind of like this wasn't
that bad I'm giving it a seven closer to
the eight and a six John's reactions
will be be on this channel don't worry
Cruz Rivera I appreciate the super chat
but why'd you redact that message was it
a hateful comment yeah or bring it back
or did you reconsider Your Love of
whatever Channel it was Cody Castillo
shouts out one Omni media what's up Omni
media is a [ __ ] I got another reaction
plan to do with him oh look out that
Cosmonaut variety hour nerdy wave good
good shout out he's in the thumbnail you
turned me on to Cosmonaut Cosmonaut
um he's some people could think he's uh
he even did a video ask uh that was
about like is he a contrarian yeah yeah
yeah I think in some way sure maybe but
not really uh I'll just come across that
way I think his videos are I believe he
edits those himself and I think they're
wonderfully additive with the best
amount he's got such a great balance of
it never feels like he's trying too hard
to be funny they're so they're so
thoughtful they're they're more
thoughtful than I think people get give
him credit for because they're they're
insightful yet
um they're consistently funny and he
puts so much effort into the editing
like there's a lot of people where I'll
just because even for like it's funny
with like Mr Sunday movies to make a
little comparison you know I I'll listen
to the weekly Planet podcast and then
sometimes I'll watch when they isolate a
segment from their weekly planet and
then they make a video out of it like a
13 minute video out of their podcast uh
Caravan yeah caravanic garbage or
something and then you go back and watch
the editing of it because I'm like all
right even though I've already heard it
I want to go back and watch the video
because
the same way how I applied with Mr
Sunday movies let's see the same thing
Cosmonaut variety hour is that part of
the voice of it is the editing and the
the inserts and all those little nitbits
that they do I I think are so good and
Cosmonaut is someone who uh I'm very
very impressed by like a lot of these
people who I who I love I think I'm
I I have that feeling I'm not worthy
I'm not worthy to talk to you and uh
Cosmonaut definitely provides that
feeling too sure these videos because
they he deals with so much getting
blocks and everything like that which is
a real bummer
um uh but he he'll take a while to put a
video together but whenever they come
out it's I'll I tend to prioritize like
I'm going to get around to this video
today I will get around a cosmonaut
variety yeah of course that's good
that's nice and he can be he can be a
little bit uh cynical too but he's he's
just not afraid to go against the noise
I love how honesty sounds he seems like
a very very honest guy
somebody said my opinions are confusing
I would like to know how I might be
talking about camping uh John I can't be
look at Toby Maguire's junk Cruz Rivera
oh there we go Cruz there you go do you
think you'll ever interview Marcus from
Cosmonaut variety hour or any of the red
letter media guide I I guess Marcus
would be much more likely I feel like
red letter media would not Dane step
down into our Arena I don't think like I
think we both have a mutual uh
admiration and love for red letter media
whilst also recognizing that we probably
are not the kind of content they would
respect I I really think red letter
media would dislike us yes someone said
I put out because I did like a community
post day of a bunch of YouTubers that
um just recommending videos of like 13
posts in a day and uh I I know I upset
some people with doing that which is
funny to upset people with it as if I'm
like directly text messaging yeah
subscribe because you kept popping up in
my feet and I was like all right follow
more people I guess unless they were I
didn't mean to
I I like if I was like directly texting
you and I won't stop it I'm sorry yeah
if you have text notifications for every
tweet your Twitter you follow then maybe
that's a problem but now I was on the
community post and uh someone said I
don't know how it sounded like a joke
but maybe it's true of like I talked to
them yeah Mike doesn't like you guys or
whatever
me it's like I've always suspected that
if they ever once came across our
channel that they would not like our
Channel sure uh however I have had the
times where like the plinket reviews
which are are don't come out that often
are
um uh are brilliant they're brilliant to
me the nerd Crew videos are hysterical
they're hysterical very cool yeah yeah
like we've we once did a showdown intro
that was all in tribute to them because
we love them like I can't deny it it's
the weirdest I don't have that with any
other YouTube channel of I'm more than
confident that if they came across our
Channel they would probably hate our
Channel
and every time they drop a video I get
excited yeah they just put out that 2022
ketchup or whatever and I was like and
they post you know whenever it doesn't
seem like they are bound to a very
strict posting schedule so it's always a
bit of a treat when one pops up because
it could be a couple weeks you know yes
yes and and yeah like even if I they're
another one where it's like even if I
don't always agree with the take I love
the Rapport like especially between Mike
and Jay but when Rich shows up and any
of the other revolving door of
contributors even uh the plinkettos and
like the more deep cut like uh you know
like really bad movie Deep Dives and
stuff like that like there's so many
great shows on that channel they just
got that sarcasm and dry humor that I
just mesh with so well and yeah and
their editing style is different than
that of most YouTubers as it feels very
it's very conversational yet there's a
lot of inserts and editing but it's not
like Connecticut Snappy yeah it's a real
discussion and a breakdown and I think
the way that they weave and and you know
it's not always there but you know it's
like the set keeps you within a certain
Realm of the fantasy of the uh Lightning
Fast VCR repair but you know sometimes I
think they do a nice job of blending and
weaving The Narrative and the sketch
aspect with just the discussion aspect
yeah uh caravonte Caldwell thank you for
the Super Chat uh he said Cody leech
Cody Leach
um and then moving on to Husker for Life
109 we're also give a Super Chat thank
you Cody Leach Holden Harbin Austin
Brook all great YouTubers
um okay Cody Leach
there's been a shout out to one that he
covered that I don't think got enough
credit but it was the one where I was
like okay he's speaking the my opinion
like that that those are that is how I
feel
um and and that was regarding uh the
Dexter Revival that I watched his videos
on that and I thought they were
excellent and I full heartily agree with
him every step of the way I was over I'm
like yeah I'm on the same page with him
on it he's got a girl he covered you
watch Cody leech covers a lot of horror
yeah yeah not not as like frequently but
I definitely check out some of his stuff
as as yeah and two more more so lately
trying to put my mind into that uh
headspace because because like I horror
is my favorite and I would love to kind
of increase my ability to you know just
uh engage in the genre you know through
this media as well
um so yeah definitely get some
inspiration there Holden and osterberg
talking horror too Austin Brooks a great
YouTuber Sean Chandler another one my
dream would be to get Sean Chandler and
coin to move in a video together and
have them do a list video together my
Ultimate Dream and Holden Hardman I
believe uh he does a lot of those
reactions with where he has like my
girlfriend watches like he does his own
first time watchings sure but I believe
he does uh I I don't I've seen more
thumbnails than I've actually seen the
videos admittedly
um I need to take some time to watch
them but uh yeah there's a lot of like
my girlfriend watches this for the first
time yeah totally
absolutely I gotta check out this Wendy
goon Channel there's a lot of love room
yeah I'm Dante is a sensation
absolute sensation dude Dante is one of
the ogs too it's a primate has good
reactions Ian's says with the Super Chat
thank you I imagine uh it's a prime I'm
writing a lot of these down
I preview a lot more yeah I'm preview
I'm a lot like you guys when it comes to
watch time or I'm like I'm gonna give a
few minutes of this
nope quick enough you know but then I
eventually come back around
oh yeah I'm always like I'll go watch
the full video if there's an ad I'll let
it play
Stormy wood says I adore the world girls
and geek buddies subscribe to the World
Girls people out to the world girls
dude I don't know the geek buddies check
out that black phone reaction
uh yeah the geek buddies that sounds
like a fun that's that reminds me of a
SpongeBob joke actually I'm writing
we're we're I think we're both
oh yeah
I got one Mouse John let's keep it going
yeah yeah yeah yeah we got this we got
this righteous Rob thank you for the
Super Chat buds I highly recommend Super
Chat there's no button why I can't hear
things
there you go there you go I highly
recommend you watch or react to Destiny
he is a gamer and a YouTube debater what
that sounds fun is he a master at
debating you know we don't need to react
to everything I'll watch I'll probably
watch
all this content yeah imagine if this
was a live reaction where everybody
could just submit a video that would be
chaos we did it once we did it was a
that was you can't it's easy to manage
yeah I don't know if it's live video and
it got blocked while we were alive yeah
yeah it's a difficult no it's a
difficult task admittedly
Cody Castillo's shouts some love out for
John Rocha film punch
um oh okay blind wave is uh Pinnacle for
TV show reactions
reactions but TV reactions here Kings
dead meat too shouts out definitely be
taking some kill counts in dead meat
James we knew we met when we went to go
do a a thing for the nun in Mexico and
um so we got to really know him before
we got to really know his content yeah
and I've never quite had an inverse
where I've really gotten to know this
guy before I know his content
and I hate his content and then the next
time I see him I'm like I've seen so
much of your content that I forgot what
it's like to know you as a friend now
that I'm now nervous talking to you yeah
totally and it's still that way for me
who would that be changed yeah still
that way like I've been to uh been to a
couple of things he's held together and
uh my wife gets all got along with him
wonderfully yes they've talked a bunch
about wrestling a bunch and he he pulled
off the impossible and he was he was a
big Saving Grace I think for the channel
um in terms of uh inspired me to take a
better lead on the reins here because
the when I met him it was the time of
the this time of adpocalypse when when
limited ads were introduced and then
everything in this channel just tanked
for like a year it was it was a really
strong tank for a year and uh and I
found out that he started his channel in
that year and got a million subscribers
and it was doing all the kind of content
YouTube is not like yeah
violent copyright based stuff and and
I'll never forget the feeling that uh he
left me with was just not getting
consumed with comparing yourself to
others and just doing what you love to
do and and techniques what you got to
handle and that that never left me and
so he was it wasn't necessarily like I
saw his content I wanted to do that it
was who he was as a person that really
inspired me yeah so um and I think and a
lot and the next time I saw him I told
him about that because like the channel
was dead on a big swing up again and I
was like thank you because it if it
wasn't for meeting him I wouldn't have
had that emotional thrust to wanna like
all right I need to change my I need to
change my ad it's safe for things to
change you have to change and then for
me I was like I need to change the way I
think so
you could change I can see it
includes your commies
did on that recut of Rocky Ford he ended
it with each common bastards even you
coming back
and everyone just slowly stopped the
Clapping
uh if he dies we killed him film punch
take it away wani been watching you guys
for seven years wow really thank you
yeah so you're the goat that is a goat
thank you a few you didn't mention which
we intentionally didn't to leave you
room microwave Society hell with that
blind wave screw him Razzle pretty much
it
listen let me explain I I actually
watched quite a bit of Let Me Explain
love lme P.S let me explain really helps
out with when I'm like what the hell
happened in this season I gotta react to
this next season yeah good combination
review and breakdown MLM yeah really
like I really do enjoy his stuff and uh
and yeah like there are certain times
where I know I can't watch the video
Until I've seen the movie at those times
it's one of those channels where I'm
like ah
I wish I I yeah I wish I was caught up
enough to watch this I don't know Razzle
but I'm seeing a lot of love for Razzle
in the chat and also I don't know Razzle
congratulations to P.S I started doing
YouTube regularly in 2022 so you are one
of the best YouTubers of 2022 film punch
thank you thank you don't know Durham
Watkins 3.7 million dollars each for you
guys to not watch Avengers King Dynasty
and Secret Wars would you take the deal
yes sure oh yes for 3.7 million people
could call us sellouts and I would be
like yep I just have 3.7 billion dollars
you be offered that opportunity and not
to try to avoid I would gladly have that
reputation yeah
I could retire like what do you expect
for me at that point how did you make
your fortune a literal Monica
self-control that's that money in real
estate yeah and I changed my entire
existence five times over probably more
than five a hundred times no one would
ever offer that but who wouldn't
yeah that's not selling out I'm
surprised Natalie gold does not have a
million Subs she really deserves it I
think CinemaSins is still pretty good
Husker for Life 109 Comics explained is
another great Channel sure that they are
um shouts out to comixology as well
comixology is a great one uh oh what is
her name oh there's a there's a there's
a hold on oh fine who else is in that
thumbnail John that we have not talked
about uh let's see talk about Cosmonaut
red letter Mr Sun things talk about
everyone I think we have right now we
can talk about whatever we want good
yeah good got it out of the way yeah we
got them all we got them all we talked
about Jeremy Johnson struggle nation of
course we love Seven Nation I've had one
of those guys on here a few times
haven't I yeah we text once in a while
don't we yeah
yeah where's he at bring him back I
don't get him to move here
I just realized Mr Sunday movies and
Double Toasted are my favorite channels
so it's either I I love the whitest guys
or the blackest
I mean you know Marcus is kind of light
skinned so I guess you could argue he's
kind of in the middle he's right George
kind of patient I can't tell
looks like he's a little Asian he could
be it could be a little multi-ethnic
yeah
that would be more interesting I want to
start leading with the fact that I'm
Filipino you should every video should
start with Pinoy Pride
I still I need to continue God or
Ragnarok it's really easy for there's a
reason I don't do gaming videos because
I can get so into gaming and then I'm
like after too much time gaming you
focus back on editing yeah or my writing
yeah and then because I can get like
when I was replaying The Last of Us um
in the middle of last year I was like I
didn't do anything else if I wasn't
filming or editing I was like I I was
just only playing The Last of Us and
losing a lot of sleep to play in the
last yeah it could be really really bad
for me aggressive comics with an X she
hasn't posted in a while but I really
liked her reviews and stuff like that
she would do a lot of movie based
content as well as like comic stuff but
uh but yeah I liked her stuff a lot so
check her out give her old videos some
love Brandon Hogg
uh thank you Brandon Braden Braden sorry
seen a few of his videos before over the
years but I really fell in love with
Adam Savage's content as last year as
well as you guys too well thank you from
Mythbusters Adam Savage you know Savage
I used to watch a lot of Mythbusters and
so I feel like he's done uh he's guessed
it on Corridor crew uh a couple times
for like uh VFX artists react I think or
or else it was stunts
um but yeah I'll have to check that out
because I love Adam I I've Loved Adam
Savage in the past and I I think I
should continue to court or crew
um Corridor crew Whoa jamini man we met
them at Jiminy man uh what do you mean
that's right yeah they are something
else yes they are
not like there are some other higher
tiered category than a YouTube channel
to me because they seem like a
professional effects Studio too yeah
that that and and I love that
you sure they can get on like real
mainstream celebrities once in a while
like a Seth Rogen uh but the way they've
been able to shine a spotlight on visual
effects artists who often don't get the
spotlight sure is
mind-blowing it's mind-boggling to me
and and I really feel like they're going
to have a very flourishing career in
actual filmmaking oh sure so they they
really seem like there's some
because I think they can graduate
like they can have a whole new court
what I'm trying to get at is they can
have a whole new on-camera Corridor crew
at one point while they're doing bigger
movies yeah they can have different
people yeah who are on camera they're in
some other Next Level tier that's
somewhere between YouTube and because I
know they're not quite there yet with
the mainstream filmmaking but I already
feel that way with yeah you know yeah
well just today in fact they put up a
video earlier today where one of the guy
they made a point of being like uh Ren
is out sick uh uh oh I forget what his
name somebody's filling in and he's the
only one who's actually worked on
professional projects and I was like
really that blows my mind though I think
they all will though and yeah the
platform they give is is a very generous
one too and the videos take so much work
yeah one I remember like being a little
mind blown because we met the guy who
supervised Spider-Man No Way Homes
effects and then he wound up on the
couch and I was like I was just talking
to them and he just looked like a guy
like he was you know like you wouldn't
necessarily we know and I think yeah
it's cool it's like people you wouldn't
necessarily suspect or who wouldn't get
the spotlight then can and two I mean
shouts out to their other videos as well
because I do like more than just the VFX
artist react series I feel like that's
probably easily their most notable and
easy to point at thing but like when
they're doing render challenges or or
you know trying to you know do some kind
of retake on a movie and make it more
violent like there's so many different
cool ideas they have that I love that
they apply there like huge wealth of
skill too
yeah yeah yeah good craft Channel
fictional darling ooh a lot of these
like female YouTubers lady YouTubers so
I was a female native YouTubers are they
are they on camera or or voice over I
wonder that zzz Day Star Wars guy I'm
seeing a lot of love for that what would
a Better Call Saul reaction even be like
umave has done it really all right I'm
doing it tonight we're gonna do it all
of it I mean that's definitely a show
I'm going to comprehensively sit down
and watch I I do want to I've been
meaning to get in touch with Eric uh
from blind wave to see a little bit more
about
how their operation runs because I'm
under the impression
that they just sort of film and they
have someone do the thumbnail and
someone do the editing and stuff and I'm
curious to know how the full the full
production goes with them yeah
it's probably much more complicated than
it appears from the outside yeah no yeah
of course
I mean it's kind of the thing with our
stuff too yeah except we don't really
have it like that right here at the
point of YouTube is to make things look
effortless
Fuso and Jordan Fringe damn you guys
watch it's kind of cool getting I mean
having people show up here even and then
it's not like you know sometimes you go
on other people's lives there's like
thousands of people watching when it's a
topic like this we always expect like
yeah I'll be like two to four hundred
people
um so it's kind of cool they actually
get uh an idea of uh of like what you
guys watch too I want to shout out those
algorithms sometimes you get these
analytic [ __ ] in your in your YouTube or
like your audience also watches these
guys but then you guys name off all
these people like I've never even heard
of these people yes you know I want to
shout out there's a guy who I saw do
stand-up comedy I I went I I happened
upon a stand-up show because I went at
the recommendation of a mutual friend of
ours and I wound up seeing just amid the
the nice run this guy called Tony Baker
and then years later discovered he had a
YouTube channel where he does a lot of
different things but also reviews and I
think his reviews are also hilarious
like his stand-up comedy if he ever get
a chance to see him live go but look up
Tony Baker on YouTube and social media
because he does a lot of funny stuff but
I love his movie reviews like he's got a
a great blend kind of like Double
Toasted where it's like a great
conversational like you know he's got
that stand-up kind of you know humorous
uh air throughout but also like you know
uh good perspective solid takes you know
even if I don't agree with him I'm
always interested to hear what he has to
say and I'm always typically laughing my
ass off
so uh get the pistol go check out Tony
Baker uh I feel like we fell behind here
on the chats John it's okay we have the
Super Chat window as well we have we
have yeah
there we go I'll just do a refresh
yeah
so many good YouTubers out there it's
nice to see the look there's too many
they need to be stopped theirs needs to
be a quote sometimes I do get
unreasonably paranoid that that we'll
just like I'm just like YouTube is just
like an ever expanding archive so like
there have to just be more and more
servers for all this right
yeah we run out of space or will we get
to a point where there's like a critical
mass and like things meltdown
uh okay elon's
yeah oh yeah we need to play some catch
up here really quick definitely
we went on too much of our own tangents
here I think we're at lit fuse because
we got Brighton Hogg
we did uh Comics explained yeah where
are we lit fuse right here all right
John do you do the thing you do John we
need to play some quick catch up here
then we'll bring back the chat oh no
well I we know who to go to I'm gonna
Destroy Everything by uh maximizing that
all right guys here uh that's that's the
way sometimes we we talk a little too
much about our own own things we want to
talk about in the meantime I'll shout
out some other channels Heroes reforge
is an amazing reaction oh yes uh out of
the three of them Adam is the one I
definitely know best
um I think he is a they are all Hector
Navarro I don't quite know that well but
every time I'm around him I always
wanted to know I do I do use that guy so
sweet he seems sweet but I've always had
nervous around Hector yeah because he's
got such clout yeah it's weird he has
such an approachable friendly and and uh
enthusiastic quality and yet I get
nervous whenever I've seen him very
nervous about Hector and apart every
time I see it he says hi to me but I'm
always like I don't know how to just
have a conversion with you I feel like
I'm overthinking how I talk I feel like
I'm looking miles up at you yeah yeah
yeah yeah for sure and then sometimes I
say that to people like I'm honestly
nervous to talk to you like sometimes I
say that and that helps sure sometimes I
say it and I go did I just put myself
down like I'm beneath this person
you should be thanking yourself that you
get to talk to me all right I do get in
that headspace well it shouts out
because anytime you see one of those
remote collab split screens uh Adam
halavik was was hugely instrumental in
giving us the tools and resources to
make those things possible because
because yeah they had been doing that
during the pandemic and everything and
and yeah they they taught us what they
know
uh lit fuse GD
faves are Corey Kenshin Eric Van which
is an anime channel okay Eric Van
wilderman that's Wilder of all the
Rama's brother cool you guys uh the
burger guys are the Burgers and Fries
yeah 3C films the Communist
communist channels
communist cooperation Channel yes
exactly uh grion which is uh all Family
Guy Brian uh YouTube proops and Tech
Source which is all about uh nature
Vlogs yeah definitely we have all we're
writing all these down when we have all
them here they're in an archive I just
realized which always refer to the Super
Chat log because everyone in the chat in
the in the in the super chats too has
been referenced in the actual chat as
well uh well thank you thank you for the
recommendation Mr Gomez
oh my God how of course you mean they're
kind of known they're very they're well
known they're especially I think for a
lot of the the ones that have a bigger
International reach the normies Mr
dumbass thank you very super chat the
normies are great the normals I met a
couple of them they're amazing there's a
bunch of norms supposed to have met up
with them when they visited LA and
unfortunately couldn't make it happen
due to the time but
I forget where they live they live in
like the Midwest somewhere I think it's
like Ohio or Iowa in the most normal
blind waves like Ohio
uh but yeah enormous I believe we're
Midwest I know era from blind wave has
created them as the best reaction
Channel ooh so you heard it and I said
you son of a [ __ ] you never mentioned
yeah
all this work
for nothing
Star Wars explained Molly Sky talkers
yes Stars explained is great by the way
thank you Mr dumbass every time I see
Star Wars abbreviated as SW I have to
redirect my brain late night reactor
love you guys love the trailer and
Theory reactions appreciate it love you
thank you late night reactor what is
your Channel about I wonder only
reacting to things that take place at
night and only reacting to them shooting
at Night trailer reactions are fun yes
I've gotten to the point now where I was
like so much editing goes into the
habits of the uh like shows and movie
reactions it's like if let's give you an
example if something like 80 minutes
long like a movie or something that
could take like me personally that could
take me like five to six hours to fully
cut together so with the trailer
reactions I'm like you know what you
guys are getting this wrong sure that's
that's how they that's the new president
for 2023. it's either yeah yeah it's
either a big a thick boy that gets a lot
of attention or it's a bite that's just
a bite yeah no more or less than it
needs to be and then those will get the
most views and people will say we put no
effort that's that's the way that's the
way it goes Neil Varma
uh I don't know breaking points ooh but
we do know we do know Perry we do know
our parents love Perry full reviewer she
has been popping off in the past year
especially like in terms of you want to
talk like brass tacks YouTubers doing
the best in 22 and Beyond I think Perry
is killing it
host and Live Events and stuff and she
was she's one of those people who seems
like she was born for this absolutely
yeah big big admiration for Perry elon's
musk back at it my personal top five
YouTube channels of all time penguin
zero most critical oh I've seen Penguins
yeah James Lee
okay don't know James Lee When de goon
and Kane pixels dude I know at least one
of them I've seen this we know one one
Penguins react to some wild stuff in the
past James Lee
Bruce Lee's other son he sounds like he
would be the director of the trifecta of
James Wan and Justin Lin and James
the Lesser note third of the whatever
pack whatever whatever you want to call
the Asian directors in Hollywood
there's got to be a brat pack rhyme that
incorporates Asian culture you can leave
it in the comments if it's not racist
yeah yeah
it's a problem still try to sometimes I
use my Filipino blood as a way to think
I could get away with so too many of
these jokes of funk well yeah okay pixel
uh came pixels yeah I want to super
quick without wasting too much time I
want to Super because game pixels have
been come up quite a bit here in the
chat and I'm sure it's not the story of
Cain and Abel they got two million Subs
I'm just gonna subscribe to them right
now
and then put your own purse that way I I
just know don't follow the crowd gee
Aditya tripathi I got to know your
channel three years back through jabby's
Channel at the time I didn't know he
even had a brother since then I have
been a subscriber and saw all your
videos I just love you both John achara
love from India
ah yes it's a real rejects love plus a
shark
which which tar is great female
YouTubers let's do this uh love a turtle
thank you I'm always happy when we got
people from other parts of this world
who actually watch us it's the most
exciting thing yeah
yeah that's funny to me is that most of
our viewers are from New York and we're
in LA and I didn't know that until
recently that's so cool yeah I feel like
that gives us a certain level of East
Coast Credit we could easily be like you
know
I'm walking in yeah I'm reacting it I
feel like a New York State of Mind is a
little bit more like if this reaction is
not entertaining me I'm gonna move on to
the next one you gotta do a good job you
know I don't got so much time whereas an
LA reaction viewer is like oh you don't
see all this goose
if I'm in a New Yorker with that accent
I'd be like
kind of annoying
just don't go to Long Island you'll be
fine Vista 47 100 you keep it 100 my
dude I love you I hope you're doing well
oh it's interesting thank you Mr Ford a
new guy
it's fun bearing it up Mr Beast because
there's a channel I do watch called The
Tabernacle oh yes it was a British dude
who's constantly uh talk it talks a lot
like entertainment media and politics
yeah about it and I I think he's a
really actually really enjoys videos a
lot yeah and
um
he like really doesn't like Mr Beast I
find a lot of people who don't like Mr
Beast doesn't matter Mr Beast is one of
the biggest YouTubes he's the he's the
biggest YouTuber I think any time
anytime the Crux of most of your videos
is obscene amounts of money then I think
people will just take issue it's like
there's some [ __ ] thing about your
philanthropy yeah yeah um I feel like Mr
Beast who just hit I want with that
being said I thoroughly enjoy the hell
out of Mr Beast videos sure there's just
so tight they're tight they're so
adhesive enthusiasm entertaining and you
know what once in a while yeah I do get
emotional when you see the reactions to
those I think they're I think they're
really fun and they're they're crazy
they're crazy videos that cost insane
amounts of money and he's always acting
like he makes no money but I'm like you
got to make some money
you can't just be give it all this away
yeah you're not you cannot be Robin Hood
outright his whole life is based on I'm
pleasing the algorithm yeah I think I
listened to his Joe Rogan interview and
he his his obsession with understand
like he has an obsessive way of thinking
about things and and it was like a level
of work ethic because you know anyone
who decides to make this their their
living does develop a bit of an
obsession uh when you're branching off
on your own and because you kind of just
have to uh but his was like that's a
whole new level of obsession that is
multi-billion dollars Obsession I do not
know this level of obsession that is
that is because it was like oh no you
know for me it's it's like yeah this
this is a massive chapter in my life but
I I also have other things that I I'm
trying to pursue as well
I am pursuing they're doing good yeah
don't yeah don't sell yourself short you
are pursuing shut up John soon I will be
I will be choking on your dust
be in jamming sindelar I love your
little uh guitar play and profile pic
thanks for the contribution buddy 3C
films he's got one of the best movie
news channels I love them big big love
to 3C Channel awesome I do know Channel
Channel awesome is like a collective
right no no no am I mistaken no or am I
thinking of Channel 101 wait a minute
isn't Channel awesome
Holden Hardman a lot of shouts after
Holden Hardman Natalie gold Ryan George
Sean I think I shattered out enough I'm
just subscribing so that way that way I
make sure I see their [ __ ]
vicunia that's a cool name I've never
heard before
and of course the real rejects are my
all-time favorite YouTube only say that
if you mean it only if they're here
contributing they must have some type of
like for us leave a like by the way even
on a live stream it helps out a lot
um Armando Rosas thank you for the
contribution here Highway uh I've met
your boy roshi
I once had a big meeting with a bunch of
reactors this is a real real big meeting
where we're all collectively coming
together being like there's something
going on with the copyrights I mean it
was a real like serious talk where we
are we're all trying to figure out
what's going on
um and uh yeah no your boy roshi he's
killing it he's he's really killing it
he should be there there's sometimes you
see things where you're like the reviews
are so big why and people put so much
weight and emphasis on subscriber count
when I'm like oh just don't avoid rosh
like he's doing better than us you know
sure we technically have more
subscribers he's undoubtedly doing
better than us and his his videos are
very entertaining I watched some of his
Wednesday reactions recently oh hey I
gotta check those out I mean it covers
the anime A Lot really well uh Cobra
Kyrie I haven't seen his Cobra Kai
reactions dude that's exciting when we
catch up for season six if you haven't
seen your boy roshi she watch him and if
you do watch him you haven't subscribed
Please Subscribe because the Dude
undoubtedly if there is so much emphasis
on subscriber count uh she deserves a
million Subs yeah yeah Kyle Kozar
kozaritz excellent YouTube channel
defunct land yes cool [ __ ] check out the
video on the Disney Channel theme what
is that it's fantastic what's defunct
language the funk land they go back uh
if I'm thinking about the right one I
thought they I might be confusing it
with something that goes back for uh
like old like abandoned theme parks and
stuff like that or like things that that
were and are now not that are like
Disney related at least when scrolling
through the video is it maybe I'm
thinking of the right I mean you have
already subscribed to them for us okay
because I know I've definitely seen some
of their videos it might be yeah is it
more about yeah yeah I know you're right
you're right yeah I've seen some of
their like you know here's this old you
know here's an old theme park they
attempted and what it became later and
and yeah
I do a lot of interesting stuff I love
stuff like that too like I don't watch
it always consistently but I love things
that are like let's explore like this
theme park that tried to be and was open
for a few years and is now abandoned or
something like that like I've also been
getting into like and I always forget
the names of the channels but I've been
watching a lot of science [ __ ] lately
yeah
um yeah tea magic sauce Michael here
t-magic Infinity
highly recommend you watch Greg Alba
from real rejects him and John Humphrey
are great it's all John it's all me
objectively I built everything you see
before everyone
John has a Solo Channel coming it's to
compete with Eric voss's new channel I
have a Solo Channel idea that is
absolutely stupid and I will make it one
day
what is it I'll only tell you the title
what is it corpse in a thousand houses
nice it's gonna be good I I just want it
to be it's the demonetization for
talking about dead body I know that's
the problem but I don't care it'll be
innocuous enough that I think I'll have
a a leg to stand on when it comes to Pro
protesting I support it thank you it'll
happen it'll it's it's the kind of thing
that should be very easy uh logistically
finally get rid of you yes this dumb
thousand dollars I wanted to uh move on
to do corpse and uh thousand houses so
you know it's Gotta respect his decision
and then after a thousand episodes I
come crawling back I've got nothing I
finished it the project is complete I
couldn't keep it forever Dan v900 thank
you Dan v900 for the Super Chat comic
Pop I wonder what that's about Owen
likes comics
I do yeah these are all these are all
three like choice because comic pop is a
good like brand name it's good solid
glass sand media oh that sounds
interesting Owen likes Comics is like
very absolutely what it is and caped
Joel I can see in my mind oh yes I have
seen these guys uh I've seen last name
media at least I don't know about the uh
comic book I feel like I've seen kompop
but last time media I'm familiar with
dude these are all going to be new for
me thank you I love a new wreck I love
discovery
Discovery Discovery righteous Rob
sending out another Super Chat just to
make sure you guys check out Destiny he
is a master debater and gamer and his
vids are very entertaining his bout with
red pillars
oh good is he is he taking on some red
pillars over here let's do it
I wanna I wanna see that
uh yeah okay I'll subscribe to Destiny
let's see how that goes like we're I
want to bring back the regular chat soon
yeah because I'm trying we're trying to
play catch up here because we lost our
spot shouts out to wise too much time to
wisecrack too I once saw Jared from
wisecrack at the mall and then I saw
Michael from wisecrack in North
Hollywood so I keep seeing wise correct
contributing let's try to bring it back
now John okay what do I do uh first you
will want to change the dimensions just
oh okay oh let's figure this out because
I think we've caught up because changing
the size will destroy everything so we
can't do that all right let's do it
let's do two more here and then we'll um
then we'll uh yes okay okay I'll watch
some Destiny first yes I don't know
about reacting but I'll watch some
Destiny I appreciate righteous Rob I am
your density Aditya tripathi I uh you
would like I think you would like to
react to any Indian YouTuber you should
try Carrie minati yalgar who I
definitely pronounced right uh song the
story behind this uh the story behind
this is he made a YouTube versus Tick
Tock video which was going to be the
most liked YouTube video but got deleted
by YouTube and this is his diss track
about it got deleted dang oh I bet
that's a fiery dis YouTube is cracking
down dude people got beef with the tube
the other bean
and they keep I asked about like who
runs YouTube again like I don't know who
runs YouTube especially lately that they
keep having these things where it's like
hey guys there's a bug or something and
your channels are all messed up now
we're not gonna really give you any
insight on that so hang tight but
they're being very very strict like
things are just demonetized like crazy
right now
um
every one of these live streams goes
it gets age restricted that's why we're
uh watching our words a little bit yes
snoopers gonna appreciate the
recommendation we have this year now
yeah oh yeah this is an archive
snooper's gonna snope this is from
snoopers gonna uh this is from snoopers
gonna Snoop your channel during the
pandemic is one that I really made me
one that really made me invest and go
for it you guys got to see how close
John is to this screen
it's you know sometimes we read stuff
and I'm like it must be because the
angle John is coming from where he's
having a hard society and John is like
this close to the screen he's like a
screen this screen is so good right
there you're still such a weird
relationship
this is a great Ultra wide screen every
time I engage with it it boggles my mind
I've tried editing on this screen and
I'm like there's just so much I just
feel like I'm I'm holding a panorama
let's take this from the top this is
from snoopers gonna Snoop which is
evident because you contributed uh your
channel during the pandemic is one that
I that really made me inve it's that
straight eye down here keep screwing me
up is one that really made me invest and
go for it and I wouldn't be here without
y'all so thank you uh thank you thank
you no way that is the coolest and I
love your Prof is that all right I can't
tell if it's a picture or a piece of
artwork but I love your profiles I type
in snoopers you're the first thing that
pops up
all right we I have subscribed subbed
see you and your girlfriend who is this
this looks cool to you and your boss
[Laughter]
this is uh
sticky situation
which one of you is contributing all
right let's try to bring this back John
yes absolutely okay we can do that uh
okay all right there we got the chat
back let's check wow
we should just bring you into Fruit yeah
we don't we do we know we lost it and we
lost our spot we can adjust it uh no I
think we can get back oh thank God all
right I guess we'll I'll guess we'll
just keep this size and I'll scoot over
here
we can't just move this in a little more
no yes okay you're good you're fine yeah
all right we're gonna figure this out
I'm gonna Center this in real time yes
in real Tim oh we're gonna go so real
time I'm gonna lower this camera a tiny
bit too dude okay let's just reset the
entire slightly fix this whole frame all
righty
but we gotta be a little bit more
efficient here with talking about
all right slightly fixed all right we're
decently centered all right scooter left
the tap it John yes yes
and at some point we'll check the
Streamline that's hurt we don't have any
stream left do we I don't know we object
go refresh it while I've catch up here
whoa we missed here keystroke commands
it's probably fled door with a bunch of
one dollars
left
we'll get to you shortly fourth with
Aisha Jutsu I don't know who that is
let's do that anime reaction a lot of
peers how could I that's who I should
have put on oh I'm like [ __ ] I totally
drew a blank there off to you I want I
totally watch Alana appears I feel done
now I should have put a lot of Pierce on
there all right I'm getting her confused
with the makeup artist no no no
is she a makeup artist no you are you
you know you might have seen
um uh she actually hosted the Cobra Kai
Netflix
okay I mean she but uh it's a lot of
gaming and stuff Long Beach Griffies I
love the team j3 entertainment now Long
Beach griffy is very problematic but but
also funny dude funny I love lockers it
makes me laugh and Caleb's Caleb city is
like the less problematic one the PG-13
version yes Caleb City and uh and Long
Beach
just doesn't give a [ __ ] man yes I don't
know how his content survives on this
platform I don't think does he post to
YouTube anymore does he I feel like he's
cut has he not posted in a while I don't
think I I saw at one point him being
like I'm gonna post stuff elsewhere or
maybe on like a patreon type of basis
because YouTube is whack but I I don't
know
uh I hope I'm wrong Jake call BP thank
you buddy big fans guys
they're big fans guys there's a big fan
right up here stuckman and Double
Toasted are my faves and also shout out
to Austin Burke underrated movie
reviewer a funny guy check him out I
appreciate all the love Austin Burke's
been getting in this chat yeah
absolutely lovely and that's a lovely
like uh array because I feel like
stuckman and double toaster are like two
ends of a spectrum and then you have
Austin Burke nicely yeah it was fun
watching their interview together
stuckman's you know
high energy delivery
Focus and uh yes stuff and then just
just calm down it's always the only note
I ever have for that guy is just like
slow it down I don't like this hyper
Force energy barely hear what you're
saying frustrating Deja always watching
shouted you out in the beginning of this
chat yay at the very beginning what's up
Rebecca Fitz and I appreciate these
recommendations female reactors there's
a lot more love Steffy from in my humble
opinion I'm gonna do a day where I shout
out a [ __ ] ton of reactors because all
the subscribers
go watch these people instead
that's good I love when people separate
their names Steffy this underrated one
who deserves more love who has like 920
000 subscribers
you know uh yeah oh well I guess I I
thought in my humble opinion would bring
it up but you got it so we're good no I
don't think that's her yeah
you got it John got it we got it maybe
use your phone a little we did it all
right I'll use the phone
um Dan v900 near mint condition for
upcoming Omni buses why are we out of
focus I don't know I think I wonder if
it's because of how far apart we are
is it focusing on like a face in the
background it could be
it's hard to say what's up Watson what's
your favorite YouTuber come here dude
Vsauce Michael here I love good Vsauce
video Even though
oh and and let's condense this chat how
do we how do we minimize this [ __ ] we
got to be closer to each other yes uh
well we can do the warp thing because
you guys this is behind the scenes live
we're gonna warp this chat a little bit
so that it's like a little taller
and skinnier but now we can sit closer
together and be in Focus hopefully
hopefully we'll see I made a mistake of
putting a Walter White Face in the
background this camera autofocuses on
faces hey Watson You Like Walter White
too Watson come here buddy just right is
a great Channel as well like a lot of
Just Right videos
I was subscribe to coffees we're
subscribed to Coffee Zillow yes yeah ooh
Dan v900 near mint condition for
upcoming omnibuses ooh for all you comic
book readers out there if you guys
subscribe to bad badass is in the chat
oh what
oh
hey
dude Bad Medicine welcome thank you for
joining damn bad medicine you're killing
it killing the Gam
oh yeah no I saw your black phone movie
reaction damn that's a movie I still
need to see you haven't seen black phone
I gotta sync up with your reaction and
watch it you don't have to do that just
watch it on your own yeah guys subscribe
to Bad Medicine they're great four Dudes
yeah it's in a massacre
and AV you know so many of these names
you guys are listening I'm just like
[ __ ] I noticed these guys before
and there's also like other
um
cinemasker oh yeah they're a massive
Channel they're cinemassive there's
other channels like I watch a lot of
video essays and um Watson say hi to the
chat uh who's your favorite YouTuber
Watson who's your favorite YouTuber it's
probably soothing Cat music or like a
video of a bird
what's it
a land that deserves more loves
Mac Murdoch Mac your friend Mac is here
what'd it do Macklin how you doing buddy
it's good to see you oh dude's killing
it out there Mac has so many talents you
know Wednesday was the first person in
this chat to show up I know I was so
excited happy yesterday Birthday or
Whatever month your Friday the 13th
birthday is it Star Wars explained
um I think is a wonderful Channel I like
Star Wars Theory a lot too oh I saw that
you're I saw that like lovely comment
you just left for yeah Star Wars
definitely didn't get any negative
comments back on that one ever but I
appreciate the like that was like a real
ask
thoughtful comment like you know I
admire your Outreach and your enthusiasm
like a lot of people on this channel on
this platform
you you you you do uh there was a joke
coming there and it just didn't matter
so it just became a stutter
the big llama show just wanted a shout
out that I'm a long time fan way to
shout yourself out that's awesome to
hear that's great news well done as a
result of watching your videos it
motivating me to start my own channel
great job yeah go big llama that was the
whole point of starting this channel
because I want other people to do their
own channels and subscribe to the Big
Love More reaction channels I say no
congratulations keep it up
um I really respect the try guys for
navigating the Scandal uh yeah you know
I saw a couple of the try guys at an
event and I didn't say [ __ ] you didn't
try to die
yeah I see it happens to me a lot I see
a lot of big YouTubers that I as much as
I love like watching people most of the
time I don't approach people unless I'm
like I'm gonna really regret I need to
even if it doesn't go unockwardly
because I'm I'm late to discover we're
trying to get focused I'm late to
discovering the try guys I started
following them shortly before the
Scandal to Choice it's like not too long
after I start following them the Scandal
took place I've taken in bits of what
the Scandal is and I still can't figure
out if it was like a a truly big deal or
just a big deal in in the bubble I don't
remember exactly what it was I didn't
really fall he's cheating on his wife
she has wife with someone I think at the
company
okay doesn't mean that's a that's not a
good ethical line the the the I was just
saying that because he sleeps with every
woman that's why there's no more woman
on this channel sorry man she sleeps
with all them that's right that's how we
vet them
if you get along with me you've got a
job you think me puts me saying that
would get John in trouble but then more
women just you want to be a star you can
shoot us up to come on the channel
did someone react with it you gotta be
willing to getting John more action for
some reason this is my dating service
absolutely Chris alirez
or a layers or a Liars the way John
campia has built his show and growth has
been crazy lately the way he breaks down
movie franchise finances is crazy plus I
love his rage rants absolutely gotta
love a good camp year rant oh can't be
as a beast well deserved man because it
always work for like other people and it
seemed like he really found his best
footing when he went solo
um we've learned I've learned a lot from
campia and um I talked on the phone with
him actually very recently uh he's he's
a he
he's actually I I like champion
I like him want that to be said going on
record yeah yeah the polarizing figure I
know that in the Twitter sphere he can
be sure I don't know as much about on
YouTube but I know on the Twitter sphere
you can be but I'm like
I don't know I'll tell you guys he's
always been a nice Academy
yeah he's done some things where I'm
like whoa maybe not what I would have
done but also yeah like I I definitely
tune in and enjoy the show the
commentary this [ __ ] is he always wanted
to be the ESPN of movie
absolutely so much emotion I love that's
why this rage stuff is great because I'm
like you I've I've never seen him do
this outside because he's a passionate
speaker sure
even in like one-on-one he's a
passionate speaker
that's good he inspires you and then you
feel like you're the only person in the
room when he talks to you I feel like I
know internet
Jack Septic Eye uh we met him once I was
nervous to meet him because I definitely
watched his videos yeah yeah he's been I
mean he's huge anyway but he seems like
he's only getting Huger
internet mom Ash
Star Wars Santa that sounds like fun
you know magic another good reactor
while we're on the subject of reactors
um uh Magic Maggie ooh it's a great one
great reaction Maggie that's a good name
magic Maggie's last dance copper what
are you trying to do here are you trying
to hop up behind the computer Tafe at
Alba
at Alba uh let's go thanks Bad Medicine
it's Tully Phillips uh Filipino Creator
or something is that why this is only
for you
who's tally Phillips I don't know I
don't know we gotta find out
Sally Phil I don't know the names of the
people at uh Bad Medicine I feel bad
let's see
I'm gonna look up bad Mattis I don't
know the name oh damn shouts out who are
the two guys damn oh what's their
Channel called the normal show
is that what they're called we were
talking with them at Avatar
and I felt very embarrassed for not
having a better lexicon of their videos
two guys Brothers both Asians
just a normal show just the normies yeah
there you go just just the normies sure
is it is it I guess I would have gotten
oh [ __ ] wait no no I'm glad you got me
confused yeah talk to them for like an
hour uh I know them for the Warren yeah
I've been I've been listening to more of
their stuff lately which is why do you
feel even worse Justin Norman now you
know somehow you saying that I mean
forget uh no they they're huge on Tick
Tock like so many followers millions and
millions of followers in there and they
have a podcast here on YouTube we'll get
there we'll find it just just uh
oh my God John why'd you say that
just the regular just the average just
the just
just sort of a basic the two Asian guys
the two Asian guys the brothers are
amazing watch so nice yeah they were so
great so now I feel even worse [ __ ] okay
right there right just a Rob with a
great profile my God you are really
insistent on this buddy Destiny versus
Jesse Lee Peterson debate is Iconic
please react to it if you can or have
the time love you guys keep up the great
work well I really appreciate that I
will I will at least probably you've
been so insistent on it that I'll at
least watch it at some point or listen
to it yes I don't know if I'm gonna like
sit down and just watch a hold of it but
maybe it depends how heated it gets yeah
like that Kanye all the Kanye and uh
Pierce Morgan stuff oh fun fantastic
entertainment fun [ __ ] oh God I only
watch side men and VFX stuff I came into
your live stream to tell you yeah I
didn't watch anything you do unless it's
those couple of corridor crew reactions
from way back uh G Kobe P also shout out
to cinema therapy ooh you know which uh
there's a lot of like break you know you
got channels like Screen Rant Looper
what culture which is making the news
lately for great things uh I really uh I
really love Cinema cinefix a lot I think
there it really feels like film school
when I listen to them ooh if you don't
want to pay for master class go watch
go watch them Cinema therapy
we did Cinema therapy once oh therapist
reacts that's cool ooh breaking down the
psychology oh what a great idea all your
fave characters sorry I can't see my
patients today I got movies I'm watching
up that's that's what I always wonder is
when you see like Dr Mike I'm like is
Doctor Mike a doctor anymore or legal
eagle does he like practice law anymore
he makes so many videos I love a legal
eagle video well I used to I actually
went to the therap
um there's what's the movie the gift the
gift of Joel Edgerton and Jason Bateman
I went to see I went to a therapist
and uh she had like a therapy company uh
like other therapists under her and her
house is where they actually shot the
gift and she was the strip doctor for
the gift to make sure it all
psychologically lined up and was
accurate to how this would play out
that's cool that's to me that's like it
it's like when you hire uh we just saw
best of Brooklyn Nine-Nine that did uh
what are they called consultant
consultant yeah yeah Consulting
producers have not seen pop culture
detective trash taste podcast I feel
like I would love Cinema therapy I did
not know this channel I feel like I
would really love this it's like it's a
perfect conversion it's the exact kind
of thing I would absolutely adore yeah
no it's definitely gonna have to
therapist reaction to movies that sounds
like really awesome I I feel like
especially if I'm a writing perspective
I think you can learn so much and that's
the version I I am there are a lot of
like you know like a therapist or socio
oh dude Mr 47 Tony Baker is dope uh
there are a lot of people who do who do
reacts to like people mannerisms and
stuff and I get a little wary of those
when it's like we're doing the Johnny
Depp trial you know breaking down every
single facial tick but in a movie
setting I think that's great like I
would love to see that for a movie
setting Harry Mack freestyle rapper ooh
who's the guy who does the Eminem
does the Eminem oh yeah oh he is so
funny I could put an arm bar in a parked
car with an aardvark in a parked car
it's like huge on Tick Tock and YouTube
now yeah he's so funny I'll find his
name
um Eminem voice
I can't do it he gets the perfect like
nasal you think he'd be the first one
that pops up when you type in Eminem
impression I know little Windex yeah a
little one deck he's if you guys ever
seen him Impressions those seven
impressions are [ __ ] Top Notch and
they're [ __ ] and the bars are good like
they're silly but they're [ __ ] good
yeah he's got it down to it science yeah
that's who I think it is oh my God
Flickinger Mothman the flick pick
dude shout out to the flick Pig
yeah I'm sorry you didn't make the
thumbnail hung out with him quite a bit
in uh in Zurich Lucky Ducks screen Jack
is doing screenshots on a show we talk
to each other very very once in a while
because John Flickinger is always moving
I don't know what you were like a nomad
you're such a she's like a trap
every like three months I'm like he's
packing up and moving it does seem like
your your life is a constant of people
yeah and you still maintain the buffest
physique no he's very jealous of thanks
for stopping by dude
I think he had some of the best uh
edited movie reviews too I love your
just out of the theater reviews as well
yeah
um even when I don't agree I loved how I
love how matter of fact and straight you
are with stuff yeah
send me some dick pics uh adventures in
Lauren land thanks thanks John for
popping in here man
a little bit nervous oh my gosh I saw
his face
what's he doing a live stream I watch a
lot of your I lost a lot of your
playbacks in your live streams uh
adventures in Lauren land just hopped on
I don't know if you mentioned already my
God Bad Medicine is taking over this
live stream they are former I didn't
know this about them this is just live
stream has been about learning about
them goody uh their former wrestlers
bodybuilders from Wisconsin and watching
them become fantasy nerds has been
highly enjoyable that is awesome I think
we gotta collaborate with Bad Medicine
they're they're even in our chat that's
insane they should help me get in shape
yeah to both of you guys just hit me up
afterwards and uh set me up with a with
a workout regimen so I'm not always
staring at this reactions going my damn
belly's back
um Cosmonaut variety hours a great
YouTube damn Bad Medicine yeah I think
I'm just gonna watch all their videos I
want to shout out real quick I love a
good music uh I like music YouTube as
well and aside from needle drop who's
like the biggest so it doesn't really
you know love the needle drop obviously
but Todd in the shadows is a great
Channel he's always profile Shadows but
he does these great breakdowns on pop
songs retrospectives on one hit wonders
and retrospectives on albums that ruined
people's careers and uh they're so great
like I love his personality they're very
well researched go check them out
uh Timothy reacts so many great new
channels now there are a lot of great
channels there are so many channels John
how come you're so awesome what is your
secret uh CGI CGI and uh you know a lot
of makeup
uh Mary Cherry I wish she continued the
boys reactions because her reaction to
season three episode is that the way to
season three season three episode one
was
hysterical I thought you had the best
made her stop watching the show because
it's too much for her but I thought it
was the best reaction to it I was like
this is a problem and I was like oh man
you should have continued and it's too
much thanks for a good reaction should I
hate Washington Mary do it my brother's
Channel hate watch if you're a woman uh
meet my brother and he will undoubtedly
bring you on yes no no woman excluded
from the Japanese
you're a woman all right come on what
are your qualifications 2x chromosomes
let's do this uh damn v900 thanks for
the Super Chat thank you all who have
contributed uh comic pop has a a video
weekly covering a comic story in a funny
way what's going on are you cats
fighting
what are you doing your cat's fighting
you guys you guys can't fight not now
no
no
knock it off you two no
you only want the chair because he has
the chair all right if he didn't have
the chair you wouldn't give a [ __ ] guys
it's okay guys this is the cast YouTube
right here it's okay is uh is these two
it's always ton Cafe
I mean
sorry I'm used to saying Todd and copper
um as a package because of your favorite
animated movie Dan v900 thank you Danby
comic pop has a video weekly covering a
comic story in a funny way casually
Comics is done by Sasha wood we'll cover
crazy old comics on camera all right
Sasha wood it is I love a crazy I'm
going with uh casually comics
again more female YouTubers let's get it
going yeah buddy let's get that female
YouTube sphere
and do check out pair weight just uh
because we're we're knees deep into the
show now it's been a while but yeah
check her out
should be going places too
here's your Forge is awesome and she
views
one protagonist dead meat is the best
horror movie review yes they are yeah
most likely great what are your thoughts
on Tyrone Magnus
moving on
[Laughter]
no man I still talk with Tyrone I
I don't see eye to eye with him on a lot
of things but I'll say that
what I the thing is is that how do I
explain this in a way I know I know he
can also be a controversial person on
Twitter
it was fun when
um him and scarlo came by and when they
visited LA and and then uh he sat down
with my wife and I am I what my wife
[Laughter]
sit down together and
when it comes to opinions they are very
opposite sides of this fact
and even I can do and I I and this and
the thing I respected the thing I
respected
when sitting down with Tyrone was we
could actually have a discussion and it
wasn't a he's trying to change my
opinion or he's or he's like fighting
with me and to me I was like all right
we can still be friends there's a level
of tolerance as long as like we can have
a discussion then we're good and it
doesn't have to be look it's just
[ __ ] weird so yeah I know he's become
a bit more controversial for some people
uh why ever would that be
we don't have to talk about right now
well I want to see plane I saw that
first thing before I saw the movie plane
before I saw the trailer for playing
which popped up as a as a pre-roll on a
video on my TV it was I saw the hashtag
plain movie and I just burst into
laughter and I saw it was Gerard Butler
and I'm like this all lines up I love
Gerard Butler because now he makes these
movies where you're like this looks like
it would be stupid I've heard it's it's
not bad I feel like I feel like Gerard
Butler is the Liam Neeson of that's not
bad I thought it would be really bad I
know his movies always look terrible and
then they get like decent reviews he's
always so surprised I'm always sad that
the Gerard Butler star didn't go to the
heights I think it could have however I
think he has managed to straighten his
career out to have a yeah to have it be
that like even if it's not great stuff
it's usually stuff that's like a good
time for what it's doing and I think
that is a solid Lane mg MGK
definitely gotta check out Machine Gun
Kelly's disrupt I like uh I like John
bernthal's podcast quite a bit real ones
yeah I kind of hate the title
I hear what you mean I like John
Bernthal and I and I like to listen to
him he seems like uh you know a truly
enthused and interesting thoughtful guy
even though he also looks like he could
smash you
Hector and coer are my go-to comic nerd
experts oh they do know their [ __ ] they
do uh I do incredibly play a movie I do
want to see playing
yes yes I know Mel verse
well good for you
I'll check out mailverse too yeah I like
malverse quite a bit uh oh you know what
else I like is Billy binges Billy binges
yeah oh timate reacts is getting some
love and is in the chat
I love that there's like usual love
being ping pong back and forth in the
chat Cemetery reacts um or is it Timothy
it's pretty cool to see you in here man
I remember uh
oh which one was it uh it was either
um my God it was either in Kanto or
Moana I I watched a couple months ago
you're you're welcome
um yeah it was like a Disney one because
you sometimes you do them with like he
would also do like remote ones with uh
other girls and stuff and oh cool and he
he's got he's got a lot of good editing
in yours too
I don't remember we haven't shouted you
out you just been here I feel like
yeah but I've totally seen your videos
he's got like 100 000 subscribers right
killing the game look it up yeah I I've
seen your videos
if I not mention that I feel like if to
me and my head it is the first time this
street in my head I've been like yeah no
it's I'm used to seeing Timothy but I'm
like no I'm not anyway don't worry you
made it in though yeah we've got you in
thank you for being here which one was
it thank you for sharing some love
oh I saw your Megamind one as well
and Kanto was the one I watched
um
and then oh Coco that was the other one
yeah Coco yes that would be a good one
okay
massive movie reactions for some of
these Disney ones okay massive ones I'll
compare my own to yours
yes yeah I'll do the same thing I'm
gonna react to the exact same way say
the same things you say and see if
anybody picks up on it yeah no Timothy
reacts
wait a minute did I see that because I
thought you were at 100k
dude you're 3K waves if you guys watch
your Timothy reacts and get this kind of
100K subscribers because holy [ __ ] like
he's only 3 000 shy
um and he's got some but he's got some
great ass videos If a hundred of you
should get 30 friends to sign up he's
got great videos
if three of you just find a thousand
people to sub he'll be there John
ortalaza ooh wait who's mg I don't know
I typed in mg while we were talking yeah
I I I just default to MGK when I hear
that or the old car I'm not finding um
it's not popping up is it short for
something I started John ortola I
started my channel the head he's project
test project
in 2020 reviewing film TV reacting
unboxing took a Hiatus I'm looking to
make a comeback in 2023 love you guys I
make a comeback in 2024. 2028 dude you
gotta like really let people miss you so
when you're back people like whoa
you know a year or something like that
or you know a couple years people were
like oh oh yeah this Channel's still
here it's been a while since a like just
a pure movie review channel has taken
off huh
it seemed like that was one of the go-to
things you you could do yeah like oh man
look at Jeremy John's Chris stuckman
schmo's no yeah the thing that you would
go to I also like anger Joe a lot
um but that seemed like the thing that
people were trying out now I feel like
now more people
pop off doing something else and movie
reviews too as part of it yeah yeah like
movie news or something like that and
then why are all these emojis not being
allowed in the chat I love them because
it's being read a Spam that's too many
Galaxy Geeks no Galaxy Geeks you're one
of the best you are oh always showing a
large show some love to Galaxy Geeks
people everybody at Galaxy Geeks and
tell them that you love them
unconditionally
yeah and then go to the quartering and
then oh just the quartering I haven't
heard that name in a long time are they
still around no Galaxy Geeks look just
four days ago they've been catching up
on on my hero Academia oh my God I'm
such a dick I thought we were subscribed
to you guys I'm sorry how could you
they're great they are they are a
fantastic Channel
fantastic Channel fantastic Channel ask
anyone they'll tell you
I mean like look at their Mario like on
their Mario trailer you guys can't see
this but like they have like this great
background for it and pronounce Mario
they they have this setup where it's
like screens in the background and they
they change up their backgrounds and
their videos and it's it always creates
for a more Dynamic viewing experience
like you're gonna yeah like in a studio
we got uh we got T right the the
previous one up just which one I think
you go up a little bit we got a team
magic Infinity right
you got that one no ah cool all right
team magic Infinity movies with Mary and
subscreen are great
subscreen is the YouTube channel created
by Ryan Gosling's character from La La
Land where he just rants about jazz
and how inauthentic modern jazz is I
have subscribed to so many people today
there are so many reaction channels now
it's crazy dude it's a it's a legitimate
Lane to exist in now even YouTube
there's certain people oh I have seen
subscreen yeah for sure
there's so many channels there's so many
reaction channels that's what keeps you
humble in this among other things in
this business is like whenever a
YouTuber meets the president I'm always
like I've never heard of this person and
they have 10 million subscribers and
they're apparently like the most popular
YouTubers in the world and uh so yeah
YouTube is like a big just a bunch of
fish bowls and you could be huge in one
fish bowl and everybody else and the
other fish bowls is like I have no idea
who you are so there's a constant
potential for Discovery Lo-Fi hip-hop
girl I'm gonna check that out Timothy
reacts talking about editing takes so
long yes but you do especially with the
remote try doing the actual editing
sorry I had to slip that in there
said the guy who does not edit the
Lion's Share the Timothy reacts editing
takes so long indeed but you got good
editing I assume you edit your own
videos
classic is is is
she's got her own Funko Pop now
or some kind of Pop
uh let's see Heather gear Heather sexy
reject Heather gear John only says that
about the woman yes I've never said it
about flev Doris hey look at this super
sexy reject over here yeah and then
finally we were just like that's what we
have to call them because John just
won't stop
Yes uh we should read those three blasts
we should from super sexy rejects no we
got a few more here I just want to make
sure on top of this you guys real
Rejects and Omni media have really
helped influence interesting
conversation topics for the podcast I'm
a part of so thank you whoa why didn't
you list with that podcast shout
yourself out give yourself something you
know what that is John you only talk to
the women so do you do you know what it
is if you watched my psych reactions you
would know I talked to everybody for too
long
everybody
even the people who don't comment
uh can I just search Heather gear and
find yourself didn't pop up Sean oh you
yeah I can already see it all right look
we know where we are
it's okay send us your pod send us your
pod and we will patronize it oh dude how
many media's uh uh internet is terrible
and I laugh at him
I want him to join the real Rejects
dude first time I've said that publicly
no he's but I've talked to them about it
we've had serious conversations we're
like why don't we just like bring you
here bring Michael D this is let's just
come over here let's figure it out man I
don't need to be here dude we got a
trifecta all right it's gonna be too
complicated to bring this up on screen
at the moment so I'm we're gonna read
this sure Flav Doran yes got a stream a
stream Lab here starts down here it's
got three
yes he's got a smart cookie here Smart
Cookie
within the reactor film sphere
I like blind waving the normies the
latter can really match your guys's
energy prove it prove it normies yeah
there's like 40 of you reacting no
wonder how do you enjoy it on your your
32-inch television normies on your
projector screen or bigger than the
whole room and stuff other YouTubers I
really said so what part with the door
wizard I'm like that's too many people
to be watching this when they have like
14 people with other YouTubers I would
really say how do you guys split the pay
[Laughter]
I would really suggest checking out Ryan
tranz I survived I dab I've seen that
he's a massive YouTuber have you guys
have you seen his videos oh they're
great he's [ __ ] huge all right Ryan
in your hands I survived on pretty much
a penny for 30 days best use of vlogging
and storytelling creates great
narratives of them undoubtedly these are
those are those are really entertaining
but he's so huge right now it's huge
some other ones real life lore Gordon
Ramsay is
great ad educational current events
funny story vids Wendover production
same as RL plus her second Channel jet
lag wow fun travel contest videos
between nerdy friends for some laughs
Michael Reeves and will Osmond both
self-taught Geniuses we are self-taught
geniuses and self-proclaimed
and then the Michael Rosenbaum podcast
that's true oh yeah I like how it's not
inside you or whatever yeah yeah I want
a successful TV show so 10 years from
now I could do a podcast going over
every episode that is a popular thing
very nice
he does like actual big interviews
though talk fill and uh yeah that's
that's cool Welling that's right they
they started a pod together that's right
doing the thing I said yeah no wonder
you said that I want I want those for
like shows that lasted uh like six
episodes
[Laughter]
yeah yeah canceled series and then
you'll get like the bonus like oh we're
talking about the the unaired episode
seven like when Mr Sunday movies did
that for the the Nick Fury is that what
the show was called the woman's
Hasselhoff the Nick Fury one I'm like I
would watch so many of these if there
was like ones about canceled like failed
TV Pilots yeah ones that just can't I
got canned after episode one there's
gotta be a show about that yeah that is
like dedicated to that or or shows that
like Pilots that got shot but that never
saw the light of day that show they
they're always watching on King of the
Hill with the priest who says like they
made a live action version of that I've
always wanted to try I'm only scooted so
far in because of the focus no John we
can do it we'll do it oh Janine's in the
chat Janine I'm trying to bring her on
the channel we'll get there we'll get to
lose 3.5 hours away and I was like never
mind Janine is the truth we're gonna try
to get out it was like considering like
maybe pair up for Last of Us I'm like
that's 3.5 hours yeah our schedule
consistently have to do lots of things
can go wrong yeah yeah maybe start with
a movie let's start with like one thing
yeah
no it would be so cool to to have Janine
on the channel yeah I want to make it
happen and keep a look out because
Janine has been working on some badass
scream content coming up
in preparation of scream sex Aisha Kenya
starring Jenna Ortega Aisha Kenya hey
Aisha we love having you here
so sweet
John Rita please this isn't a movie
channels so we're not going to talk
about it
JK but Andrew huberman oh yeah
definitely listen to Sam Andrew huberman
is a neuroscientist who provides really
helpful vids for mental health great
channel to follow also therapy provides
great vids for mental health too in real
life without the border of the screen I
can't wait for AI therapists I'm writing
a script about it's going to be good I
just want to be able to just anytime I
want to I want a therapist that you
planted the brain and I could just have
him with me everywhere taken in every
problem every conversation is just yeah
and it builds how does that make you
feel I'm just trying to have dinner
right now
I really want I saw there you AI makes
for great memes and I saw a meme
recently where somebody had had an AI
take in all of these Hallmark Channel
movie scripts and then write its own and
I think that would be great for therapy
is if somebody just took in a bunch of
transcripts of therapy sessions and then
because you know what you get will be
halfway thoughtful and halfway
inexplicable and I love I never want a
AI to reach its peak for for that reason
I always wanted to be a little bit like
what
I know previewed I'm subscribed and
previewed yay they are funny Timothy
reacts Timothy reacts in the chat
definitely check out pretty much it and
Bad Medicine dude Timothy reacts you
know what I would do dude if I was you I
would because your face looks it enough
I would figure out deep fake technology
and do all your reactions do like a
month of reactions as Timothy shallow do
that and then people think he's actually
started his own channel get into a legal
uh situation
speak your face would match up just
enough yeah you shave because you
usually have like a little bit of facial
scrub if you shave you could do it
pretty much it I have all pretty much it
get that to me just the nobodies
just a nobody's moving it up right now
cz's world's pretty much oh my God
I don't know pretty much it
dude well now you have to react to all
their content I always want to get a
real emergency call on a live stream
John I gotta go it's okay just do the
rest of the super chats without me I'll
explain later
and then he never explained later oh my
God one of the first off-topic
conversations here grid 414. space ice
is great if you love Nick Cage Van Damme
Steven Seagal good bad movie late night
laughs well thank you grid414. I
actually do space ice Christ love a good
bad movie I'm gonna get John react a
street fighter I would love to do after
you cover all six seasons of Better Call
Saul I will do I will happily do all of
these things like I I would be thrilled
to do bad movie reactions I would love
that if there was a market for it that
is there is it's called bad movie remix
well sure but but well if it fits into
this algorithm I would be overjoyed to
do some terrible movie reactions yeah
man I love stuff like that I grew up
with Mystery Science Theater it's in my
DNA
not good movies do you think Street
Fighter is a bad movie or something no
Street Fighter hey never insults the
Damian Chapa classic Street Fighter dude
come on I'm going to kick in bison's ass
so hard
are you going to go home
let's go
let's go game
oh oh my God John it's such a such a
good movie I know it is
so stupid it was so good
dude it's the best we should do a street
freighter reaction together I don't care
how good Last of Us ends up being it
will not compare it will not compare to
Street Fighter Street Fighter movie dude
it's impossible Street Fighter movie is
from a special time where they took it
kind of seriously but they didn't have
enough to make it what it truly could be
I don't think they really took it
seriously somebody did you know who
didn't take it seriously Rob Julia he
really
he was the only one who was like I know
which movie I'm in he is no one else
does but I know you think he played the
game
you know I'm that Ming now when
ah lucky I met Ming now when lucky and I
sometimes I I feel like I say the wrong
thing when I meet famous people
because I'm like I'm just gonna say my
honest thing because they're not gonna
remember meeting me I'm just a fan
they're not gonna remember me to me I
like they could approached her morning
noon and night by people this is not a
big deal for them so I'm just gonna say
what I honestly want to say
this is just after book of Boba Fett
ended I could have said loved you a
Mandalorian
I could have been [ __ ] and act like
I've seen Agents of Shield I couldn't I
could have said just finished the book
of Boba Fett you were the best part of
the show
but when I met her I said I grew up
watching Street Fighter
I went to Europe I went to her work from
like 25 years ago I don't go out of the
book of booth that ended that week and I
said and she's like she's like oh really
that's what she said oh really yeah like
that's that's what I went with that's
good she's here to live like that week
especially I'm sure she heard a lot of
boat book of both but was that [ __ ]
yeah book of [ __ ] but I was like
come on people really didn't like that
show I'm not gonna [ __ ] you no
Street Fighter legit she was always good
in it but yes Street Fighter for sure uh
Ali wants and Moolah zoo and that bush
is an artist for Lucas Arts thank you
for the Super Chat by the way that is
not overlooked
with a YT Channel and John has worn his
zombie warship
oh really cool okay yeah yeah the blue
yeah the the baseball shirt with the
blue sleeves I love that t-shirt in fact
I almost didn't get one because they
were sold out but then they brought out
another batch of overflow
which is a riveting Tale But I'm gonna
have to check out more of Matt Bush's
art hell yeah other channels shouts out
to Freight rags
french-tastic Explorations Star Wars Meg
sounds like a lady
french-tastic Explorations are those
like Vlogs in France the try channel is
that the try guys Jamel no it's not the
tri-channel uh oh no no that's the one
where Eric Horseman recommended them to
us
is that there were like Irish people try
different foods
or is that Irish people try I think uh
no no no it's more it's they've had
videos like that I'm not sure if it's
only that but yeah is that like one of
their Series yeah like the the try guys
do like crazier [ __ ] whereas this is
like my guys are like I'm gonna get it
uh what's it called to put a tube up
your butt and you you will flush
yourself
yeah I'm gonna get a colonic sure okay
where's the tri-channel is like we're
trying yeah
yeah we're drinking only kinds of
whiskey today or something we're both
really entertaining one's just doesn't
have a scandal
Jamal uh Julia nylon and fictional dark
I feel like I know fictional I
appreciate all the lady recommendations
yeah guys we'll do this again next year
and it'll be only women on there yes one
only one specific demographic I know
fictional Hispanic oh oh and also oh my
God uh what's her name is it a man man
did the Jedi I want to say sure with the
red hair
yes Amanda the Jedi she's great oh and
I've seen Julia
you're just gonna recall them look how
dude you guys you just gotta watch them
more so they come to mind first so I
react to a late night reactor
um so I write all things from music from
all over the world even anime songs from
metal to bands from Japan mainly oh cool
you know there's an app
um oh my God a music guy this is what
you just told me that's why I benefit
you if you just Google it you probably
pop up there's this app that allows you
to get radio from anywhere in the world
so you can get it like you can just
change it to like a country and it'll
tune into like what's playing I don't
know what that app is called but
especially for someone with your kind of
content I feel like that would behoove
you I've never cared for it because I
latch on to like the same 20 songs for
like two years and then I move on
John has a as a big palette to paint
with with all these different songs and
I'm like I got like a few because I'm
working on a story
this is what my mind is attached to it's
okay I've let go of the purism or the
elitism of music everybody enjoys things
differently and has different purposes I
was in trouble your hardest working 20
year old
he always says that yeah good for him
he's got big it was like a video like
one or two times a month there's huge
ass videos though they're great
reactions each one it gets like a
million views dang really he is the
hardest working 20 20 year olds in the
world the internet's busiest hardest
working 20 year old Nadia is
entertaining ooh
there's some good music artists
uh you don't like anyone recently I've
seen this guy yeah yeah okay I've seen
Dylan he's got a very Charming face
Wednesday Nadia ooh check them out
Kimberly
I love you guys we love you
also love and blind wave oh Heroes were
forged cool
my name is Ron Latino Nikki and Stephen
amazing Game of Thrones reactions who
those kinds they're funny together those
Cavazos great too wonderful married
couple
Holden Hardman I just subscribed to him
on this he's the only one I don't know
yeah I'm like God damn who who's holding
the Hardman I I I'm surprised he's so
hard wait no I do know Holman Harvest
married to the real previewed I feel
like I've seen this is cool I'm getting
more acquainted I'm getting more
equipment with other reaction channels
here
Fox machina
is that a game it's a show it's a show
it's all on Netflix Oh yeah I remember
when that came out okay
dude when's uh League of Legends coming
Arcane Arcane a hurricane toad Arcane
was it's funny it feels like it was
years ago now and it wasn't that long
that was the biggest surprise that was a
such a cool and so gratifyingly just I
had quality yeah it was a massive
surprise yeah dude that animation was
gorgeous too
near mint condition is the best chance
for all our collected Edition Omnibus
updates
oh that's cool
binging with babish this this whole live
stream has just been me going all right
let me check them in let me subscribe no
no we're getting in touch with what you
guys
we can steal all of what it works about
it I'm gonna react to all their videos
this is a reactor this is a new reactor
reaction Channel Peggy hey Peggy good to
see you thank you
it's good to see you Barry I'm Dante
absolutely Mr Beast does have somewhere
to thank people Power Crunch thank you
thank people you sound like the best
bowl of cereal my favorite YouTube
channel is Double Toasted
trash taste podcast it's been brought up
a couple times in this chat what is
trash Chase gotta find out it sounds
like they have trash taste they probably
loved uh debatable movies dead meat
definitely got Big Love For Dead Meat
watch a lot of dead meat Ryan Hollinger
our subscription feed is gonna be
through the roof and Roanoke gaming
which mysteriously disappeared from
YouTube with no Trace
that's good I get it oh I would love
Roanoke gaming damn these are hardcore
games I've just subscribed to all them
Cinema therapy I want to be doing you
guys listen to the midnight boys podcast
I believe I have someone just asked what
about John Flickinger he's in the chat
so you can send him some love earlier
what do you mean you missed Brandon
loves movies did something happen did
Brandon stop loving movies or did he
just run out of movies I thought it was
Brandon likes movies by the way
maybe he changed it from loves to likes
and that's why people miss it because
he's just not as enthusiastic about
movies anymore oh no he's been dealing
with so much copyright stuff he knows
another great reactor popcorn in bed
she's [ __ ] fantastic
and eating popcorn in bed is just a good
activity too oh damn dude I gotta be
able to help this guy out dude reach out
oh I'll extend that Olive Branch
do do one of the things you do best oh
poor guy
dude everybody I didn't know that
happened yeah dude everybody go send
Brandon loves movies some love of him
geek buddies is John Rocha show well he
hasn't invited me on yeah so we don't
acknowledge Him
because I I get back to people so late
and he like texted me and then the next
day he's like hey did something happen
between us yeah I was just like [ __ ] you
John
to which he responded yeah fair enough
I would not want to get on John roca's
back the outlaw is sad to see him mad
scared yeah it is scary
it is scary you don't want to be this
but it always makes me like whenever he
like you know acknowledges me I'm always
like when he's happy he's the sweetest
oh yeah I never want to get on his bad
side though not that he's done anything
terrible but it's better other people
who I love to get on their back I would
love yeah that can't be a right bathroom
yeah I'll be the new Jack
he'll be the guy from old collider whose
name will no longer be mentioned you
gotta like make some fake news story and
make it seem like it's real yes exactly
did you hear that Ezra Miller beat up
another person with his body
and and he didn't work out yeah he
didn't work out for the beating or for
the role and he did the beating with his
newly renewed four more flash films
contract gotta send that in and try to
get that new story out there
oh thank you
always watching Aaron and Joe
sounds really good yeah Duo gives you an
idea
nerdy nightly ooh that's a cool name Bad
Medicine the mic laws the movie buds or
channels I found recently and to suck up
real rejects is my fave nerdy Knight
dasha's always watching where do you
live you should I mean if you're in the
LA area it'd be cool to have you on
sometime
she's got great if you guys haven't
subscribed Nations always watching
please do I know I shout out the very
topics in there live stream but but do
you uh do subscribe to her come collab
we'll watch better call us all together
[Laughter]
it'll be great
that's exactly what you came here for
you know the thing is there's also
another person named desha reacts who
also pop up for a hard time
oh my God that would be amazing he's
just both of them together here
Queen tofu we're also doing sometimes
we're doing streamlabs yep let's see we
got
no flev Doran
all right here we are Aaron who is Aaron
and Joe all right I think we're all
caught up here no we're not
no John we're not we can check the the
thing Aaron and Joe they got 320k and
just oh my God I was gonna make a joke
but they I think they are two dudes
which I thought it would be a guy and a
girl but it is not
um they did Road to El Dorado
among other among many other things
they've done a lot of Disney they've
done so we're far from God it's okay
we'll get there we'll get there I really
thought we were like hey ricotta dude I
love his blind reactions
Aaron and Joe they got 114 chaos have
you guys seen love is blind those people
are nuts
do you know what it is you've described
it to me where they have to like they
what is it they you'll probably explain
it better if you would like to or I can
recount what you've told me I'm on
season two of it right now I love
watching them and judging them and
crying
sure episode I'm like you people are
insane what is wrong with you and oh my
God they really love each other
what insane for for finding love in this
weird contrived situation so love is my
guy going to attack can you load up the
super chess
over here you take it away are we always
so behind I got I got a few hours of
editing ahead of me and I want to have a
little bit of a Saturday night I
appreciate everyone was here leave a
like okay I'm gonna tell you guys about
love is mine if you haven't seen it's on
Netflix so love is blind is uh you got
like a bunch of people who like date
each other via these pods for a while
and these pods like you can only hear
each other and like there's these comfy
rooms you can't see each other so the
real test is like is love blind and then
by the end you know you decide uh like
the guy's gonna decide if he's gonna
propose and so whatever you decide to be
with you gotta like propose them you can
engage them and then you go to like the
next rounds or you're like actually
gonna spend some time to each other it's
all leading to them getting to the Altar
and the first rounds are the most
fascinating because that's when they're
just getting to know each other and
they're falling in love people fall in
love with each other without having ever
seen one another and the way it's
captured is not like your typical
reality show you're like these people
are really [ __ ] falling in love with
each other like I follow some people
from season one on on social media who
are like still together after all this
time and it's it's the gnarliest
experiment and the experiment would be
healthy I think like really healthy if
if all you had to do was go all right
after a month of this dating
being so close they're not on your
phones you can't find out who they are
like I think they take away your phones
and [ __ ] it would be healthy
to me if they just took away the whole
thing of getting married if it was like
after after the pods no you guys can go
on dates now and see if you're
compatible you put the embarrassing up
there like America two months you gotta
get married I'm like that puts a whole
new layer of pressure yeah that's gonna
stop the situation but it is so engaging
and you just want to see if they're
gonna make it to the altar
that is the only reality show I watch
because there's it's it's the first
rounds especially such a fascinating
psychological study of these people when
you're just like come on man it's so
obvious of what's going like if the
unhealthy attachments and whatever and
the and when people are lust even even
if you haven't met but you could tell
they're lusting without really
having the emotional connection or
sometimes it is emotional but then when
they meet
their physical barriers get in the way
it's such an interesting show sure watch
it you have to check us amount
we are good and then and then we know
where to catch back up with the main
chat so we're all set
right shrub did I forget to mention too
much
I appreciate it very much thank you is
dgg is that a thing is that another
Channel or is that an acronym I am
missing the meaning of
um
I don't know Ramiro aldetra thanks for
the Super Chat howdy from Texas y'all oh
he was doing this while riding a a horse
and and throwing a lasso around and
shooting his Magnum up in the air
uh while wrangling some bull together
wrangling some Bowl together did you
catch everything I said John no I knew
Jones I saw that Destiny dgg video I was
like I'm back in the room I made a lot
of stereotypical jokes we did a lot of
stereotypical do you talk about his 10
gallon hat and his six guns and uh and
Texas toast the joke is it was a
texas-sized joke stop paying attention
anyway
BP
if I could shout out some music channels
AR TV and rocked check out their Rock
Coliseum live streams there great I
haven't seen Rock John but I have seen
AR TV shouts out to John from AR TV
bring back the live streams we're caught
up hey we're we're caught up John from
AR TV I like his shout out some music
channels we love Spectrum pulse I also
enjoy
um oh there's a guy I don't remember his
name there's a guy who
um Anthony Fontaine not Anthony fantano
uh I mean I he's probably my favorite
music channel generally and then Todd in
the shadows I check out AR TV I check
out Spectrum pulse Sean C I like a lot
yeah
um Sean C TVs yes I like Sean c a lot
there's a guy who reacts to like songs
for the first time he's a black guy I
don't remember what his channel is
called and if I is it because he's a
black guy you've chosen yeah everybody
is uh no life Shack to me so
I like no life Shack when he checks out
songs and stuff like that um but he's a
different guy and uh and he'll do more
um he'll he does like a wider range of
songs but it's all like first time
hearing this and uh and weirdly I really
love first time music reactions when
it's like you know here's a big song
from the past that you know or something
like that you know some kind of it's
here's a Weezer song and let's watch
somebody from now completely removed
from the context react to it and I think
those are very very fun
um trying to think if there's anything
else musical but if there is I'll just
shout it out later how come John isn't
in the bad batch reactions for an
experiment John Commander Cody's back oh
dude love him great character from Clone
Wars I would imagine you understand why
it's such a is that crazy one it's such
a big deal the clone of you like
rebelled against the the Clone [ __ ]
right and then he was like oh bad batch
we're cool
even though you guys are in a precarious
situation yeah do you remember the last
time we saw him yeah he thought we
thought he was dead but he's not
on a scale from one to exactly right how
exactly right has all this been
CL clone Clone Wars is is a show is a
show that I will eventually have
completed I find myself having to go
back a lot which is the problem
sometimes sometimes it's easier I'm like
I want someone with me to help me carry
some of the knowledge yeah Star Wars
yeah eventually I will have all that
knowledge wealth build up but I have not
been efficient enough till now to do so
so Michael tesler is a great dude though
and you are in good hands for Star Wars
you were in much better hands than my
own I I come at Star Wars with more just
Cinema appreciation than canonical
textbook Cesar tribaldos you guys are
the best keep at it with this channel no
Caesar you and your girlfriend or wife
or sister who you're banging or just the
person at the Apple Store
when you took the picture it's a
well-fed kitty you're goddamn right it's
a well-fed kitty that cat went missing
for a few days due to some accident that
happened and then when that cat came
back we're like you're getting some food
you are getting all the food you ever
want you guys should react to Shazam too
you know what I'm thinking let's skip
Shazam in the theaters contribute to it
failing at the box office
God help Zachary poor Zachary Levi
yeah I saw blind wife put out a tweet
about they're not going to watch the
Ant-Man trailer because they wanted to
have his minimum spoilers as possible
for when they watch it I'm like oh my
God they're gonna skip this in the
theaters and they're going to are you
leaving babe leaving
okay babe have fun
um they're gonna skip this in the
theaters and watch Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania probably react to it I'm
like damn that's wild should we do
should we do that we've talked about it
once in the back of my mind I was like
even though we were laughing a lot I can
I can sense that this could turn into an
actual I mean those would be huge I mean
it would be like I think how would we
not get this but we do a lot more post
of the movie because we do like the
non-spoiler then we do a spoiler talk
live stream and then we do a breakdown
coverage and then we'll we'll talk cover
some videos that go into theories and
stuff like that so it's like we we go a
little bit beyond sure so I was like nah
we should watch in theaters
I mean yeah the problem is like you
wouldn't or we would just do one movie
reaction that was
and take care I feel like you could do
the the trouble is the timing because I
feel like you could still do some of
that stuff but yeah it's like the iron
is hottest when the movie itself has
just come out in the theaters and so
that's the thing is like I feel like
some of those extra content pieces could
work delayed by two or three months or
however long it takes to go to this and
then you combine all those videos that
we do and then they will come close to
matching blind waves yes
but I I the thing is I'm sitting here
for 2023 going one of these axes is
going to fall and one of these movies we
would have reviewed will become a
reaction the Marvels has women yeah and
we need more female YouTubers so we'll
just yeah so we're not gonna pay for to
watch it we're not going to support
women in cinema monetarily but we will
profit off of women in cinema here
that's how we do that's how we do it's
female empowerment that benefits us
do you all watch any commentary channels
like would it be more specific you mean
like a full-on movie commentary that you
would sync up or just channels
commenting on various things I feel like
I watch a lot of comments mainly what we
do is it's mainly what I watched
commentary Channel most of what we watch
is yeah commentary
listen to yeah it's like 99 of the
things people commenting on culture
philosophy Etc
Cinema gorilla music nice to see your
your name here again yeah there's a
music channel for you love you rejects
trying to get oh my God okay
love you rejects shout out to lady
genevia for movie essays and interviews
with a minist historical lens and
breakthrough news in New York to debunk
fake news oh
okay let me subscribe I do like this
idea that sounds very interesting I like
a thoughtful and a you know applicable
kind of Lifey take on anything
that's why I love like when wisecrack
breaks down a movie I think Cosmic
wonder is the best channel of all time
take his shelter devoted dog cat animal
rescue what oh instant subscribe yes
dude
we gotta react to all that content or
what do you mean our streamlabs link is
broken what'd you do John
what
what
all right all right all right how'd you
do it flev it fled still in the chat uh
you know let us know and uh we can Sally
never really seen all the MCA movies
she's seen all of them all that was a
lot
yeah yeah yeah yeah
no she hasn't seen pretty much all of
them she's only seen the Spider-Man ones
which pissed me off because I was like
no way home would have been a mess yeah
this is the one the one best ones over
so the biggest outpour but she hasn't
seen like civil war with Spider-Man she
hadn't seen Infinity war and end game
but she's seen the Standalone she's seen
the Spider-Man MCU movies okay I mean
we'll take that
which still pissed me off yeah so so
screw her where are you going John I am
pulling up this live stream and a better
version of this link why
so that people can access it properly I
guess I don't know it was working before
but now it's not working there's no need
to do that job all right no more
streamlined I'll fix it
that's it
hey we got a pre-roll to enter this live
stream look out now that's messed up
[Laughter]
why why do we have a free roll
uh because I monetize the video I guess
oh we should put mid-rolls in we will
after I think we should put mid-rolls in
while we're live streaming I think right
now it's human rolling like every every
five minutes okay guys here's the here
we're gonna do an experiment right now
because YouTube often recommends this
I'm gonna hit this insert add button and
I'm gonna and just let us know if an ad
break happens
okay ads inserted all right that's
that's that if you saw an ad let us know
and if you didn't then we'll know
um yeah
all right two seconds
I think we're still live we are still
live
I mean I I guess I don't see how it
would work the insert ad yeah how would
you keep it live inserting
a fix later you're gonna fix it for next
time I guess yeah man it was working
well I've got it to work but yeah man
yeah yeah man we're doing some stream
Labs here at the friend of live chat uh
I got this
job we're going okay and talk his shot
all right guys we're gonna speed around
some of this super fast quick thoughts
quick thoughts subscreen we know we've
talked about them yes 50 Cent should
show up in the MCU to disc King Richard
Lloyd love the one up love that 8-bit
animation good stuff Zach Pope and your
buddy Dan Merle who has the best box
office breakdowns in the world and also
some incredible reviews Zach Pope is a
great YouTuber 100 agree with you yeah
yeah yeah correct this will show up
later in your chat here the names I am
Diamond Dave yes you are Mason Quinn the
Appleton Oak the answer John yes hit
control yeah there we go I'm screenshot
yes we are that way when I meet them I'm
like you're Diamond dick you're amazing
the answer you're the Appleton Oak the
straw Chimes one bit of news
Aaron's show whoa this is usually so in
Reverse
correct you look handsome usually it's
like Greg you're fun John where do you
get those good looks oh I don't know I
just try to take care of my hair dad
Seaman and his mom's egg yeah basically
and I'm glad you like one of my favorite
ever react moments cated for that
Flashpoint video come to the chili
pepper show tonight there's a Chili
Peppers I missed Jack White last night I
was so sad I couldn't get a ticket you
fool I I know I've been trying to see
Jack White play free Puss in Boots The
Last Wish yeah I want to react to it I
want I want to re-watch the first one
first never seen it you've never seen
the first one any of the [ __ ] oh my
god dude I totally watched it baked out
of my minds and I cannot tell you out of
all of your moments new ship plot points
I have no clue opportunity not I can't
tell you a single second of that I can't
I I not even the base sick plot of that
movie how many [ __ ] boots movies we
could do a whole series oh my God
there's like 14 puss in movies there's a
whole cinematic cat Universe well yeah I
only know the Puss and Boots appearances
from Shrek so uh let's do it but some
boots it came in a Shrek
oh my God that was mind-blowing Shrek 2
still my favorite one of the Shreks
Shrek two happily ever keto reacts great
one real ones with John Bernthal awesome
we're doing okay I'm a little bit hungry
uh flick pick is definitely a nomad the
guy loves to travel Bad Medicine we
should collab please dude I want to meet
all of you and by all you I mean I want
to meet uh you know Dave and Mason Quinn
and Appleton Oak for sure maybe the
answer too
sandwich have we not shout out
sandwich for show those guys are some of
the hardest working YouTubers
six months to prepare a video
and I'm like where's the next one hurry
it up come on yeah John Denton I'm gonna
have to check that out I have not read
the TMNT the last Ronin comic
unfortunately guys for any of you Music
Channel lovers out there uh are there
any uh lady music reactors or music
content creators no everyone's no life
Shack to me
um oh there's another guy who does uh
who does music related videos uh he does
a show called why this song stinks check
that guy out when I figured Dan Dan
something or other
Dan v900 ooh breakfast all day movie
reviews and fish jelly
movie reviews where both cover Indie
movies I think I know breakfast all day
fish jelly does
breakfast all day has um has Amy Mann on
it right
um
I listen to her on film week sometimes
both cover Indie movies fish jelly does
spoiler reviews every time both are
really fun are you looking at breakfast
all day if you are I'll look up fish
jelly please
and we will subscribe to them all and
then tomorrow we'll look at our feed and
be like what is all this new content
people are talking skinamarink
everyone's talking about that I'm really
into this idea snooper's gonna snoop
snoop is gonna Snoop G Kobe P another
underrated YouTuber Zach Pope agreed ooh
100 Ren geekness ooh don't know we're in
geekness cinema wins oh my God I love
their positive I remember they
I remember we react to something where
I'm like this guy brought me to tears in
his description I think it was ryza
Skywalker related I feel like that was
one of the ones we would have checked
out
John should I go I'm gonna go there you
do that well I'll read the next seven
years
678 honey I watch all the movie
reactions and my girlfriend laughs at me
because I'm always crying at the same
time so you must be watching Greg's
reactions a lot because Greg the amount
of times we have poured over the right
cry face for a thumbnail
is a hole like Saga in and of itself
it's like a it's a facet of life here
doing a reaction I cried a lot during a
certain early 2000s Disney animated
classic that I missed back in the day
hint hint punch Buggle
is that a decent
626 voice
means hello who are we gonna watch lilo
coming out it's coming soon
and I cried a lot I cried more than I
expected to it's good
funny thing no one cries in an hour I
know I'm a [ __ ]
reaction therapy great music reactions
ooh yes for you John you already subbed
you John specifically I'm allowed to
watch it and they've been waiting it
would be fun to do some TMT reactions
I'm not gonna lie it would be pretty fun
oh dude there are so many things to
choose from I was thinking maybe we do
make we pulled the plug on dark
okay I it's persisted like it is hung
around I feel like it's
it's
maintained its cultural conversation
everybody seems to love it and it's got
like a science fictiony angle to it
sounds pretty sweet I think I know your
internet mom Ash hey I'm subscribed to
her
which is awesome the Joker is pregnant
cool which comic book is that from I
want to read it
is the Joker like a is the dragon like a
trans man interesting takes
I'm a little late to the party well
we're late to the party shouting out
late to the party for being a great
Channel always shouts out to Gator
Martin Gator original originator of the
reactors oh Bad Medicine
thanks for the kind word fellas let's
collab indeed
we'll see how much will you pay me yes
[Music]
with a hundred dollar USD this is a
bringer show you need to guarantee a
thousand views at least well I don't go
on enough channels no one's paid
yeah no I've done many
I mainly collapse uh just trust Ash cat
watch is horror Mr and Mrs flicks
Timothy there's like a whole other
community I don't know about dude we
have so much homework to do also Shaka I
like your little Shaka hand hiding out
in the yellow don't worry John soon the
real rejects will become irrelevant when
all these people take over sure they
already have in a lot of ways and and
then I will be even less relevant than I
already am not no John you're very
relevant you're more relevant than I'll
ever be nah this is because I'm white
everything is handed to me
John and Greg are the guys
probably not Greg and John are the cap
buyers of the YouTube World they just
get along with everybody not true yeah
behind the scenes it's all [ __ ] screen
Crush kill him [ __ ] hate that Ryan
error yeah he's the worst son of a [ __ ]
I never get a never get an established
title near his plot people don't know
about him is just how sexist he is yes
his wife says it all the time yeah she's
like that's why they renewed their vows
forced
G Colby P Favorite DT or spill review
Ooh vine is their BMR for Battlefield
Earth steel and both BMR and spill audio
review for The Love Guru and Disaster
Movie you know what's funny back in the
spill.com days I would listen to their
review of Bucky Larson born to be a star
when I that would be Mike my comfort
food review just going back and I can't
remember who all was even I don't know
if that was a full crew one because
there were so many I would love to go I
I would go back to there's some great
Twilight ones uh but yeah Bucky Bucky
Larson in The Spill days was definitely
one I would go back for I mean I do have
a big fond love for uh
you just posted yes such a great uh
Double Toasted review I thought when the
Tom Cruise rant came out they had the
best one about it too sure
that's still a great video red letter
media does not hate us I don't think
they would care enough about us to hate
us I just think that you think they
would be like not interested just the
knee-jerk reaction would probably be
this is not quality content yeah yeah
and then and then we're not even a
thought in their mind after that I hate
just too much of an emotion it would
just be indifferent and not but I love
them so much I'd be like it's on brand
they wouldn't like us yeah it's almost
like getting yeah it's like oh my God
they slagged us off it's so cool
we have joined the ranks of several
unimpressive movies like I want to go
out of my way to be disliked by them but
but I wouldn't hate it but it wouldn't
be I wouldn't be like oh wow that hurts
um
Jay Colby p and going back to rock
watches regretting the past videos about
albums that have an age mouth mainly
both as Simple Plan reviews ooh oh
Simple Plan remember though yeah I'm
addicted to you
dude
dude you know what else dude we're going
to Rocket Good Charlotte man Alex Meyer
is pretty funny yes I agree with this
sentiment
it's okay bud come here you can't you
guys are fighting too much you can't go
out buddy
what's where are we talking what's
what's sentiment oh Tito reacts I've
definitely seen that name around the
sphere your Green Mile reaction was
great Gene
Greg I watch all your mood reactions my
girlfriend always laughs at me and you
start crying at the same time we gotta
break up with that girl
gee it's sensitive enough for you man
yeah what gives
I've had medicine
and howdy look look at the love you get
in this chat Bad Medicine has taken over
this chat this is the Bad Medicine
appreciation hour hello chaps L'Oreal
Esquire Lori what's up how you doing
dude I need to reach out to Brandon
likes movies like hey man I know you
don't like me or know me
but I need you to know something I'm
glad you're not doing reactions anymore
if I can see there's a way to help him
out I love the Brandon Melgar chimed in
right after that comment too Ashley
Ashley Burton she's she's got some of
the biggest like older movie reactions
too dude burn popcorn in bed that is a
niche earn popcorn in bed
is a great Channel subscribe to them
oh my God yeah dude look RT TV
so long been trying to kill other
podcasts it just wasn't working out
because of the scheduling
um oh that would be so cool though Mr
downtown hey rejects we all co-host with
a campy again yeah John are you gonna do
it again if he knows who I am every time
John Henry no he does mention me
sometimes I've I've heard myself
mentioned by campia and have been nerded
out so dude Campion loves you what yeah
he calls you does he even yeah he brings
you up on conversation all the time no
he does not yeah
he's amazing he loves you he's always
like
she's like
um where's John sure yeah that sounded
like like a really solid impression it's
like he was here in the room you know
it's funny I I have history not like
channels 90 John 10 that's right that's
always supposed to appear
and he's always like I'll settle for
Greg on my show but really what I need
but really he's too nervous to approach
you sure I believe that I mean she
didn't know this John he can tell he can
tell Rob to talk to me Rob and I knew
each other back in the old like Rob
horror never remembers you that's the
sad part I don't know if he would that's
John we spent so much so much adjacent
time and no he does yes yes he does know
yeah it is yes Robert John I know John
they both know us man God damn it Jesus
Christ
I would I would gladly go on there Robin
is like when the Batman came I Rob
completely shattered out of her Batman
review
I saw that fan pops another great
channel to subscribe to please go ahead
and do it pops shout out we love Sith
Council on harloff's channel I haven't
actually watched it with Council I've
only seen big thing
dude two Star Wars eat for me you want
out chunky let him out please sure yeah
absolutely but keep that door wide open
in case we hear them fighting I want to
go on uh
on another Christian harloff joint the
the the that one uh uh a Christian hit
me up and he said that was ever adorable
yeah
um yeah we did not we can't be the old
ones inspire you to create your Channel
You Gotta Throw in like
trying to think of another Super
right-wing YouTuber dude
that was so dude I hope we run into each
other again though that was really cool
look
the best reaction to the web music video
[Music]
who's that fast talking
uh what is I I really can't recall his
name right now your boy the the guy who
everyone loves
is he a is he boy who's he talking about
wait are we are we speaking ironically
or are we speaking genuinely
or or genuinely
what is it eventually yeah that
Shapiro's reaction to that yes we are
Big Ben Shapiro fans all day every day
love meeting coin John at the doctor
strange 2 premiere
I saw you from a distance and I turned
the other way
I wish I met you man
I wish I met you but you didn't swatter
under the bridge no no next Premiere
next go to the mall right now here at
every premiere it'll be good honestly if
I can get an option for a Premiere or
screening I'm going with the screening
okay over the premiere
you don't want to be swayed by Hollywood
pampering but the Avatar Premiere was
beautiful that felt that was an
immersive event I was like oh this is
something special yeah that was
beautiful what they put together
favorite YouTuber right now is doddford
dotford
maybe a car
maybe maybe it could be
okay I really love Zach Cherry in 3C
films Janine the machine says hey this
actually is great I do like Zach Cherry
I do I do Zach Zach Pope too good Zach
does great Hort details as a fun podcast
cherry picker 3C films is a great set
does fun video intros and really funny
reviews and movie news nothing like a 3C
intro I love watching 3C blow up man
it's awesome he's in Tick Tock too he's
[ __ ] massive now I love how 3C has
yes the most he I arguably one of the
most professional looking YouTube sets
yeah I did you should check you sent it
to you the Instagram but I'll send it
again right there issue the reaction to
it buddy yeah but but here just just
just so that we're clear I've heard pod
Meets World is a great podcast for boy
me I haven't finished Boy Meets World
yet though oh could be don't don't speak
too much on that we got a patreon
podcast to talk about that on
Boy Meets World yeah
if you want to come over to our patreon
and hear a special podcast the first
half of it should be up tomorrow and
then the rest of it will have to go on
our patreon it's gonna go public it's
gonna go public but you could also check
it out
that's good now I know how published I
heard many reactors say they don't watch
other reaction channels really
I mean
I don't watch the reaction but before
mine is done but I I could I watch to
see what my reactions
and then I record the reaction you go
wow this movie looks great let me watch
someone do a reaction yes
but I I watch plenty of other reaction
channels you watch a lot of reaction
channels I watch a lot I scope I keep my
eyes Target I'm always looking for the
next reaction binge yeah I mean uh I
come from film lover world and in Film
Community World a lot of it is very much
about
you know the artboard
that's all I've ever heard but I haven't
read The Art of War but that's all I've
ever heard about that know your enemy
yeah uh no the the uh the the the
it's it's always good to know like who's
doing what and what's working and and
and and take away from what's good about
what they're doing you know they always
say the word YouTube community and so
many people I don't feel like really
treat it like a community they treat it
like a big competition field when I'm
like there's no point in doing that it's
everyone our videos are free to watch
make it a community and encourage and so
and in general is filled with overlap
and people sharing notes and I don't
think that should be any different for
stuff like this it's different I get it
for like movie theater experiences
because in movie theaters you gotta
carve out of time to go watch it and you
know really schedule that then you got
to go in there and pay and you know it's
like a whole thing so I understand the
competition angle there
um but on YouTube especially it's like I
don't I I like to know what other people
and you learn a lot from what other
people are doing heavy spoilers I think
is especially really good memory
spoilers like no everybody yeah man that
guy is is like a machine networking
coming up with like funny tweets making
these crazy ass break down everything of
course I know Sean Chandler talks about
um You probably uh super Michael on
eight raccoon
they still make videos let's find out
they were supposed to be making a movie
what happened to them I know like their
channels especially shooting the movie
their Channel especially has a really
hard time with
monetization man the the last video they
posted was from a year ago they haven't
posted in about a year
they snuck into a Mr Beast video oh did
they yeah
as per the title anyway of course we
watch new rock stars who doesn't watch
new rock stars oh the Brendan V good to
see you again buddy Brendan you guys
need to check out Alanda Parker she's
hilarious going on the list here ooh
also shout out to raise the world have
you seen the land of Parker no
enlighten me can you subscribe to her
really quick I don't know oh my phone's
here
I'm already I'm way ahead of you ombre
of course the film theorists are great
too
a film Theory
I'm like how how much does matpat's
vocal cords hurt after doing that
Greg since you like westerns would you
watch Little Big Man starring Chief Dan
George fade Runaway
Faye Dunaway
okay done away baby they run away gotta
get ahead I'm like Get Away uh yeah I
mean I don't know if I'll react to it
but I've never watch it and why not
you know a movie I watched recently I
did not do a reaction to that's right
sometimes I just watch them oh no what
you didn't get the master with Joaquin
Phoenix yeah doing his best Arthur Fleck
impression that would have been a great
reaction
this guy is weird
yeah he is that is a takeaway of that
character it's funny I I I like that
movie more than certain other PT
Anderson movies I liked it a lot I liked
it a lot yeah I was planning on just
watching like 40 minutes and I heard a I
sometimes I divide up the movies and
then I watched I couldn't turn it off I
was like I don't know why I don't know
where this movie's going
what the plot is really
what the objective is I think it's about
scientology and then uh I found myself
like but I'm really into this it is you
know it's a really bizarre film I really
enjoy just the niche in YouTube of
experts reacting to you know like ex
mafia guy reacts to Mafia scenes and
movies and there was one with a like a
an ex-cult member and she said the
master was one of the most apt
depictions of a cult on screen that's
why I really enjoyed it yeah yeah
absolutely they did they did a good job
depicting a messed up situation
all right I got it I got some energy to
do but I think we're caught up here are
we all caught up scream reactions here I
think we're caught up all right guys
what wait no no no no what is their
Instagram handle John shut up I missed
we missed a few hold on we got it here
we go we'll get there we have the Super
Chat page if we need it quite a few
no just hey Canadian lad Canadian lad I
thought Canadian lad would be
um watching the playback in 0.25 speed
today yes this is the slowest you can
get the live stream
and he found so many other channels for
us to check out whilst doing so that's
the thing
audition lives in Florida I'm looking
for send us Canadian Lads subscribe to
Canadian lad he's low on subscribers at
the moment real quick 2 million shoot us
a message Daredevil fan film shoot us a
message on Instagram that's why I sent
it to you originally but shoot us a
message on the Rio rejects Instagram and
I will send you this link again right
now and then we will we will all be on
the record for you having received it
my favorite anime is an anime I haven't
finished yet and that is Naruto second
one would be uh Attack on Titan Naruto
dude I Gotta See Attack on Titan and and
Naruto but Naruto is so long
that it's more Dawn psychology in
Seattle damn huh that's cool is it all
like psychology based romantic comedy
reactions
that would be good
I like this comment bro y'all comedy
dude we should just uh we should just do
like
we should just do like a bunch of
romantic comedy reactions yeah man I
haven't seen a lot of the classes we
look like the kind of people who
wouldn't watch many of them yeah and I
love them I know and I'm enthusiastic
about them I just haven't seen a lot of
them cried at too many romantic comedies
yeah because they work because they fall
in love they fall in love over despite
the um their inner their inner obstacles
that prevent them from fighting they run
to the airport in a desperate Dash
they did it yes cheesy sons of [ __ ]
I like King tannic he is a b very small
Channel and talks about anime and also
been on Burnet streams every now and
then well Flubber Nubs I appreciate the
Super Chat and flub nub everyone
everyone's been getting us I've I've
subscribed to maybe 30 channels at today
alone just face off of this stream
there's a lot of people who don't like
us who are getting subscriptions from us
yes
he's in flux anyone have a YouTube
channel react to the bills they get in
the mail
I love that yes that is so funny oh yeah
male reactions that'd be perfect we
react to life I wanted to do a book
reading reaction but not put on screen
oh
I wanted to do a book reading reaction
but not put on screen when I'm reading
just so it's just you killing
oh dear oh that's messed up
good dialogue movie Reading Movie
reading read the novel read along we
should do a movie reading
and then the review is all about how
well it stacked up to the actually
watching the movies I mean if actually
there is a way to do it if you had like
a audiobook and the book an ad so we
could read along that way that way we're
on the same page yeah you have it piped
into your eardrums while you're
pretending to read this cameras are
going in and out of focus all the time
David Gandy get us a new camera Marlon
gando ooh Be Kind Rewind
you're you're still playing that YouTube
video if you guys are in a paranormal
check out overnight ooh they've got
themselves subscribing
subscribing to overnight OverWatch
no not overnight train
we're doing a good Vlog about an
overnight train
oh wow oh 1.57 Milly shows chaos man
love is blind I gotta finish it love is
blind dude the bird man of course we
shout out other YouTubers
of course we do do the Canadian lad is
the [ __ ] man dude he's such a nice guy
too
Real Steel is on the list dude Real
Steel Rock 'em sock'em Robots the movie
is that a good movie John we've already
seen it but we're gonna act like we I
assume it's good no I haven't seen
everyone loves uh the guy who's
directing Deadpool 3 now who I know his
name but not now
Sean Levy yeah I keep wanting to call
him Sean Chandler because of obvious
reasons child Levy who wanted a box
match in Greg and Tyrone Greg I think
I'd have a shot at a boxing match but I
think you know like we're talking
weightlifting or arm wrestling you know
Tyrone Greg maybe YouTubers think about
how there is no longer a tube involved
in anything you do
that's what you think the internet is a
series of tubes this is a big maybe
vivsy pop shouts out to vivsy pop great
animations Travis Nickerson all these
horror reboots the one they need to
reboot is Critters and the one with the
sewer pipe one uh this is coming out of
the sewer chud chud uh yeah dude Now's
the Time who can kick higher probably
Greg I can kick higher than you would
think but Greg can probably kick higher
than me yeah
I do I still do the kicks sometimes in
the punching techniques
from back in the old taekwondo days
when's the last time you did it a couple
weeks ago did you yeah yeah when I go
out if I go especially like jogging over
the coffee shop
I do them at the coffee shop in line
[Laughter]
punch revert jab reverse jab oh this is
Phillip Molina film wise Philip yeah
that would have helped a lot to know
that at going I should know that it's
just because I'm subscribed to the
Future sorry Philip yes I'm sorry
definitely subscribed definitely
definitely guys check out Philip
Molina's Channel
did you already announce who's in it he
put out a tweet of like I got a co-host
you guys are gonna like him
I I don't know who it is
do you know who it is Phillip's new
co-host yeah I I
is it koi or something
no oh okay all right he hasn't announced
it I don't know then and I shouldn't get
it right dude
it starts with an S oh Santa Claus no
Santana no come on man you know who it
is it starts with an s s
so I don't want to give it away
tooth Sandwich Man victasia episode 2
and 3 reactions
maybe oh yes fan fictasia why don't we
do like two and when four comes out we
should do two three and then four sure
and have been a big burst see how well
they do oh Scoundrels Inc shouts out to
uh Frank janish and the crew John I
think we're caught him I think we could
be and I could start my editing projects
hey
you get it I'm just gonna make sure
oh look out look out now Cinema Sayers
podcast is the one I'm on thanks for the
platform everyone go to cinemaslayers
podcast yes
Cinema slayers
Slayer remember Halo way back in the day
I still play
but like does it still say that when you
go into Slayer mode Slayer
good
you know they're all right we know Sean
Chandler Todd I talked with Sean
Chandler sometimes on Twitter oh my gosh
that means Sean Chandler talks to you
has been Hotel uh I am very much looking
forward to that I mean reactions would
be cool it's a it's an overwhelming
animation style in a good way what is
has been Hotel Vivid pop uh hell of a
boss is also their thing it's it's a
animated show that I think a24 has now
picked up Spectacular Spider-Man with
John and Coy that's a big that's a big
maybe actually with uh them doing it I
would love that been very much enjoying
it's just Coy's rate is you know
something too much and then he like
really bleeds out the talking and I'm
like and then John doesn't shut up
either and then I'm like ah great now
they're gonna
now now I'm not even gonna break even on
investing that's what we're here man
we're here to bleed Jesus bleeding me
driving
out the hours yes
that's the secret we're like if we keep
on talking for a full hour
even more of a rate coin
that's my contribution here is I'm just
draining You by keeping koi how do I see
my most recent how do we see the most
recent subscriptions
oh on like that you yeah chose to yeah
that's the problem now is I'm thinking
we've subscribed to so many I think
we've subscribed to like 40 channels
today
all right guys see my recent YouTubes I
got a few hours of editing ahead of me
keep a lookout for Last of Us reactions
this week up it's gonna be a good week
The Last of Us returns I mean debuts but
returns in a weird way
yeah it returns in a new form
please for love God
for being you I want to thank John for
um setting up this whole live stream and
being amazing have not seen kaleidoscope
and I want to thank all you guys who
have tuned in for this stream please
support other YouTubers all the time
well koi uh has been out of town boys
now out of town really sick and then now
he's out of town
so I don't know when that new comic
corner is coming but uh it'll be here
let's uh let's all catch up again soon
thank you all for being here I love
doing these live streams there's so much
coming out right now so this is probably
the last live stream for a while but um
thank you all for um being absolutely
incredible Sophie don't worry about it
much love to everyone here John yes that
is my name uh I love you and I want you
to know that um it's going to be okay
today it's going to be okay yeah you can
go home and relax I needed to hear that
I got this handled I want to help you
close this out John all right peace out
guys leave a like on the stream thank
you for being here we will catch you
again sometime soon really just just
really appreciate all your love and
enthusiasm and
that's right be well and I'll catch you
on the next one
[Music]
and uh we'll see you next time signing
off this has been the real Rejects peace
East Jets
we're doing it where we're taking away
the super